the whole earth seemed to rumble beneath
him as Carlos Garcia stood there
standing up at the hulking shadowy Mass
towering over him his knees were shaking
and sweat was running down his face but
he clenched his jaw and stayed put
Furious voices hurled abuse at him from
all angles the stench of gasoline and
wood smoke filled the air as the
rumbling grew louder and louder gripping
the camcorder tightly Carlos pointed it
straight up at the enormous excavator
that was belching out smoke just feet
away from him angry men in high
visibility jackets hung off the sides of
it making hand gestures at him and even
throwing rocks but Carlos found much to
his surprise that his filming hand was
steady he panned the lens across the
view in front of him excavators
Lumberjacks standing on Cut Down tree
trunks as thick as motorcycles and then
up into the Lush canopies of the Amazon
rainforest with its rich dark green
leaves dense knotted Vines colorful
fruits and terrified ecosystem colorful
birds watched the scene with nervous
eyes ready to take off at a moment's
notice all of the larger animals had
either run away or been killed long
before he showed up Carlos swung the
camcorder back down to the mercenaries
chopping down his beloved rainforest and
jabbed a finger at them you will not put
your axe to the trunk of one more tree
without first cutting me down sick of
waiting the workmen climbed back into
their vehicles and started revving their
engines it was all for show Carlos told
himself that's all it was they were just
trying to scare him but it was working
he was scared the excavator in front of
him crept slowly forward with tires that
were taller than he was a foot away 6 in
away and then an inch away Carlos closed
his eyes and Reed himself to be run over
but the pain never came a whining
chewing noise came from the engine as if
the vehicle was suddenly trapped on
something unable to turn its Wheels
Carlos opened his eyes and tried to peer
around the edge of the vehicle to see
what was going on at the back there was
a new note in the voices of the workmen
around him they didn't seem so angry
anymore more fearful Carlos went to take
a step to see what was going on but his
foot caught and he was trapped looking
down he saw that he had somehow managed
to Lodge his foot beneath a small tree
route triying to pull himself free but
the grip tightened all of a sudden the
roots wound tightly around his boots
instantly crushing his foot and breaking
every bone inside of it Carlos screamed
but through the dullness of Terror that
was filling his mind he realized no one
else would hear him because they were
all too busy screaming themselves the
root wasn't just tightening around his
foot now it was pulling him dragging him
the dirt parted around his crushed foot
as the root dragged him down into the
Earth it wasn't that the ground was
swallowing him it was that the root was
pulling so hard that the ground broke
apart around his body the pressure was
unbelievable as first his ankle then his
knee and then his hip went under he felt
the bones in his pelvis crunching and
breaking as his other leg was forced
into an unnatural split it would be good
to tell you that Carlos Garcia had a
quick death from that point that he felt
no pain as his body was wrenched down in
into the Earth but no he died very
slowly in a tremendous amount of fear
and pain as his lungs steadily filled up
with Earth and his bones splintered and
crunched one by one one of the most
admirable traits of the human race has
always been our ability to find a home
anywhere from the Inu people living in
the Arctic Circle all the way through to
the ancient Egyptians building colossal
pyramids in the middle of arid deserts
Humanity always finds a way to make a a
home anthropologists can look all over
the world and find traces of human
settlements virtually anywhere one of
the remaining Bastion where tribal
populations can still exist and flourish
is the Amazon rainforest life can be
difficult and fiercely competitive but
the rich fertile ground and abundance of
food sources have meant that the Amazon
has always been home to small human
settlements that is why researchers were
so perplexed by the existence of a dark
spot within the rain Forest after
Decades of work not one trace of human
life has been found within this area for
good reason for a very good reason
Foundation agent Natalie Richards made
her way quickly down the stairs
spiraling downwards and downwards she
had never much enjoyed the Descent
something about waking up in the morning
and knowing that she would wind up back
down here again went beyond the usual
Monday blues it was more Insidious she
had barely slept all week it wasn't just
the sticky heat of the barracks at the
Paragon South America forward operating
site that kept her awake it was the
paranoia she would just lie there in her
bed experiencing these delusions that at
any point a root would shoot up out of
the ground and wrap itself around her
neck it never happened of course their
accommodations had been built high up
suspended among the trees away from the
site to mitigate any risk but still it
would always get worse when it was her
turn on the Observation Deck Down and
down she descended through the tower
feeling that horrible pressurizing
feeling that tells you you're going
further underground the air she was
breathing down here was filtered by
enormous top-of-the-line systems that
made sure the air within the tower was
clean and fresh there was an entire
department dedicated to the filtration
system set up in each of the four towers
and yet she couldn't help imagining that
tendrils of fog creeping through the
vents to get to her suddenly she was
there on the observation deck she hadn't
had time to brace herself so the view
even though she had seen it dozens of
times before punched her right in the
stomach and left her feeling dizzy on
the other side of the glass was a void
the research team had told her that it
was 53 km across at its widest point and
42 km at its deepest those kinds of
numbers meant nothing to her the reality
was that it was Darkness a rotten Abyss
open and unending she was in to Charlie
one of four observation towers suspended
upside down from the roof of the cavern
at the bottom of the tower what usually
would have been the top was the search
light its beam cut steadily through the
abyss like a lighthouse in the dead of
night the beam drifted through empty
space the only way you could even tell
it was lit up was the slight Haze in the
air suddenly the search light found its
Target just a branch at first nothing
thicker than a car snaking its way to
join with another and another another
growing thicker by multitudes each time
until suddenly the light was shining on
the trunk 380 m in diameter 9.2 km tall
the Colossal tree hung upside down from
the roof of the Void dangling into the
abyss Natalie Richards gulped and tried
to breathe deeply so as not to lose her
balance it was her job now to stare at
this tree for the next 3 hours she felt
sick SCP 6666 is a colossal Botanical
entity that can be found near the
coordinates 4° 51 minutes 29.4 seconds
South by 67° 44 minutes 12.6 seconds
west in the Amazon rainforest research
has been ongoing for several years to
fully map and understand the scale of
both the tree itself and the void in
which it inhabits project Paragon was
instituted in an attempt to understand
and one day contain the growth of this
entity above ground an exclusion Zone
has been setup covering the area where
the roots of this tree have grown
through to the surface a 1 km buffer has
been established just outside of the
circumference with a heavily armed
security presence patrolling it at all
times unfortunately due to the nature of
SCP
6666 this buffer zone has to be moved on
a normal weekly basis while samples
taken from this SCP seem to indicate
that it is totally dead organically
speaking the root system still possesses
a degree of autonomy being able to move
and grow at rates unseen in typical
plant species the roots are capable of
breaking through the surface and
constricting organic life living above
primarily targeting humans but also
targeting buildings vehicles and
Machinery it is no wonder then that
there is no trace of any human
settlements either contemporary or
historical anywhere near SCP
6666 she knew that the foundation has
been at a loss for Progress over the
prior few months their equipment and
resources were deteriorating faster than
they were making progress with their
research no one had been down to the
floor yet they were all too afraid to
descending down through the void agent
Richard saw something that made her
heart drop out of the Gap in the trunk
of SCP
6666 emerged a hand it clung to the bark
with enormous fingers straining and
pulling as the entity dragged itself out
from its Hiding Place arm after arm
emerged with one carrying a spear that
must have been 20 M long five arms in
total clung to the tree as SCP 6666 daa
surveyed the vehicle flying past it the
entity didn't swipe at the VTO it didn't
do anything to attack it but it just
watched before slowly turning its face
towards agent Richards in the
observation tower it had six eyes
arranged into columns running down the
length of its face it had no nose no
mouth and no ears but it saw her it saw
even better than she could see it she
felt Panic rising in her chest meanwhile
the research team and the VTO checked
their equipment one more time they had
been outfitted with a brand new set of
custom pressurized insertion suits but
they weren't stupid nothing was 100%
safe from reach and having studied the
fog down here for month after month they
knew just how deadly it could be if
there was even the slightest
contamination down and down the craft
descended kilometer after kilometer
through utter blackness
until through the front window they were
able to see a thick layer of fog coating
the basement of the cabin the lead
researcher stood at the front of the VTO
and gave them one more briefing
emphasizing the importance of moving
slowly and safely not touching anything
that could compromise the Integrity of
their suits in making sure to collect as
many physical samples as possible to
take back up to the surface for study
agent Richards stared at the demon in
front of her even through the very
enforced glass she could hear the low
rumbling of its voice as it spoke to her
researchers have been trying to
understand what language it was for
years now but with no luck it was either
so ancient or so alien that it was
beyond their ability to translate The
Entity had a name however from speaking
to researchers on Project Paragon
adjacent to SCP 4840 they have been able
to name the creature the demon Hector
one of four primeval entities
originating from a long since lost near
human civilization millions of years old
at least who knows it may even predate
the existence of Earth entirely of
course we can't simply mention the
concept of four primeval demons without
telling you a little bit about the other
three some of which you might even
recognize one of them known as SCP 2254
to the SCP Foundation is also known as
the demon lir much like Hector lahir is
a six-eyed being of immense power
presiding over his own domain he is
invisible to the naked eye and spends
his free time influencing the minds of
human beings when he's not impregnating
them with fleshing masses next Comes The
Entity known to the SCP Foundation as
SCP 4840 DB also known as the demon
Lancelot once a brave knight of King
sarus VII Von aoon before being
corrupted this immensely powerful being
resides in SCP 4840 the flying city of
aopa pedopolis and rounding out this
Elite group of mysterious demonic
entities comes SCP
6765 DD also known as the demon ogier a
horrific cloaked entity that sits a top
a throne of blood it's widely believed
these four entities were cursed by an
unknown and immensely powerful
phological being long ago doomed to hide
in ancient places and live until they
fulfill their true purpose playing a
part in some known event that will
someday compromise all of mankind and
now agent Richards was face to face with
one quarter of the Apocalypse agent
Richards stared as the demon Hector
spoke to her dozens of kilometers below
the VTO touched down in the fog as soon
as the deployment doors opened the thick
gas filled the aircraft obscuring their
Vision turning on their helmet cameras
the researchers stepped out into the
unknown as their live feeds were watched
by their colleagues on the surface
smooth Stone Surfaces covered with
etchings swam into view some kind of
ancient language carved into stone the
remnants of some early South American
civilization no the researchers on the
surface knew immediately that what they
were looking at was far too advanced far
too old was it was it even human at all
a scream filled the control room a
breach in a researcher suit the fog that
he breathed in contained just a few
particles set the neurons in his brain
on fire before shutting down his nervous
system entirely in a matter of seconds
the rest of the researchers all ran back
to the VTO and fear but the fog around
them was so dense that they couldn't
find it anywhere it could have been 3 ft
away from them and they would have never
even known one by one the researchers in
the foggy Forest dropped dead on the
surface the research team side en closed
the video feeds there was a reason
they'd sent them down with live cameras
no one had really expected them to
return and all the while agent Natalie
Richards stood trembling and watching as
the demon Hector hung from the upside
down tree and chanted at her in his
impossible language she didn't care what
any of the botanists said this tree was
not dead the demon readied its Spear and
leaped at her on an ordinary day in 1991
a Young Man known by the initials JS
went on a hike with four of his friends
on the wooded outskirts of their small
town everything seemed perfectly normal
until JS began to feel a strange sense
of familiarity like he had been in this
spot before he couldn't shake this weird
feeling but thought nothing more of it
little did he know that this was a sign
of deadly things to come several hours
after first experiencing that sense of
deja vu JS was found by the side of the
road covered in cuts and scratches with
his friends nowhere to be found this is
the story of SCP 939 an unforgettable
monster that you'll never remember there
was no way for JS to know that the
unsettling feeling he felt and the
horrors that followed it were the result
of an experiment conducted by the SC P
Foundation an experiment with deadly
unforeseen
consequences JS and his friends were
exposed to a substance known only as amn
c227 as part of a series of tests
performed by the SCP Foundation intended
to determine the effectiveness of this
substance as a deliberate
amnestic dealing with as many mysterious
secret creatures and objects as they do
the SCP Foundation has long needed a way
to tamper with the memories of those
exposed to the foundation's very various
prisoners and test subjects and when the
foundation discovered amn c227 it seemed
like it might be perfect for this
purpose so where did amn c227 come from
over a year before the incident with JS
and his friends the SCP Foundation
captured SCP 939 SCP 939 is a species of
endothermic predators that live and hunt
in packs they are designated ker class
and regarded as highly dangerous and
hostile to human life native to caves
they have no eyes translucent red skin
and stand at an average of 2.2 M tall
with an average weight of 250 kg they
have four limbs each ending in three
fingered Claws and a fourth opposable
digit resembling a thumb in addition to
their sharp claws their mouths are
filled with red fang-like teeth that
reach up to 6 cm in length in place of
their absent eyes they have light
sensitive spots running along their
backs which are covered in spines
believed to detect changes in air
pressure and flow in addition to their
many other terrifying attributes the
internal anatomy of SCP 939 poses a
biological mystery these creatures have
no circulatory system and no digestive
tract that's right in spite of being
Predators seemingly acting on a need to
feed they have no stomach instead when
they eat their food builds up in their
respiratory system until its presence
inhibits function and then it is
regurgitated in spite of being a
creature that should not under any
logical conditions be able to live SCP
939 continues to persist and is even
capable of giving birth to live young
after a gestation period of 12 months
the SCP Foundation was able to study a
litter of these young that were born in
captivity in September of
1992 though the creatures remain just as
much of a scientific mystery as they
were upon first discovery everything
about them seems to defy the logic of
the natural world which to be fair is
really nothing new for the foundation
yes the respiratory system of SCP 939
was found to Exhale small traces of an
airborne amnestic substance given the
name amn c227 this compound blocks the
formation of memories for the duration
of exposure to it plus a 30-minute
period following the exposure give or
take a few minutes it is colorless
odorless tasteless and completely
undetectable in the bloodstream after
only 60 Minutes amn c227 was approved
for use as a Class C amnestic by the SCP
Foundation in 1990 following some
initial tests however after one
particular incident involving a young
man and his friends the official use of
amn c227 was suspended JS and three of
his four friends were previously given a
dose of amn c227 though the details of
why they were given the amnestic has
since been stricken from the record
several months after being exposed to
amn c227 JS and his friends went out on
their ill-fated hiking trip while hiking
JS was suddenly overcome with the sense
of deja vu when he mentioned it to his
friends three of them agreed that they
had felt it too one of the group another
young man who had not been exposed to
amn c227 was uncomfortable and decided
to go home JS and the remaining three
members of the group made the choice to
stay in the woods and try to determine
what was triggering the unusual feeling
of familiarity as they got closer and
closer to a large cave near the hiking
trail the sense of having been there
before grew stronger and stronger armed
with only one flashlight and a foolish
curiosity the four went inside the cave
they made their way deeper and deeper
and deeper into the darkness not knowing
why they felt this way or what they
might find inside none of the group
could explain just what felt so familiar
only that the further they made their
way into the cave the more pronounced
the feeling became it was getting late
and they knew they should have been
afraid to venture so deep into a cave
with only one light source and no
knowledge of what lay inside
but still they pressed on one of the
group remarked that they should turn
back but the others refused to listen
they wanted to know what they were
getting close to what was drawing them
deeper and deeper into the cave
unfortunately for them they would get
their answer in the heart of the cave
was a pack of SCP 939 waiting patiently
for their prey to wander into their
domain there are no witnesses to account
for what exactly happened to JS and his
companions but we can reasonably piece
the events together from what happened
after once the friends reached the heart
of the Cave the creatures were on them
in seconds raking them with their sharp
claws and biting with their fangs
scp-939 are larger and stronger than
most people so it was probably not much
of a fight however while his friends
were being devoured JS was somehow able
to scramble out of the cave and make his
way into the woods in search of help
under the influence of the am c227 that
had built up in the cave from the
presence of the pack of SCP 939 JS lost
a large portion of his memory of the
event he found in himself on the side of
the highway late at night seriously
injured and his clothes ripped an
officer found him there and asked him to
stay still and remain calm until an
ambulance could arrive JS was still in a
panic and attempted to run away from the
officer begging to be released so that
he could get away he babbled incon about
the color red screaming over and over
again about the red though impr prompted
he could not explain what the red he was
screaming about referred to his friends
were not with him just as the officer
managed to calm Js the ambulance arrived
its flashing red lights sent him into
another frenzy and he attempted to
escape custody claiming that the red
lights were going to get him the
official police report described JS as
perhaps being under the influence of a
powerful hallucinogen that he was just
having a bad trip but the SCP Foundation
knew better the foundation conducted an
interview with JS about his experience
and determined that SCP 939 was
certainly involved as part of their
coverup effort they strongly implicated
Js in The Disappearance and the death of
his friends he was convicted of
manslaughter though the bodies of his
friends were never found it is rumored
that the SCP Foundation hired him on a
prison work release program and that he
now works as a member of the janitorial
staff at one of the foundation's
facilities this incident led to the
suspension of the use of amn c227 as it
revealed some vital and disturbing
information about the compound side
effects after the exposure to amn c227 a
person who found themselves exposed to
it again experience a sense of
familiarity and felt compelled to
investigate the source of this feeling
essentially anyone treated with amn c227
are not made aware of the existence and
danger of scp-939 would become a perfect
victim primed to be attracted to dens of
SCP 939 it is likely that this side
effect is not a coincidence but rather a
deliberate hunting tactic designed to
attract prey that had somehow managed to
escape with no memory of their attack at
the hands of SCP 939 this previous
intended prey would find themselves
drawn to the same Den or even a new one
not knowing that they were walking back
into near certain death while the SCP
Foundation suspended the use of amn c227
as a Class C amnestic they did recruit a
team of SCP field operatives to take
advantage of this side effect this team
of operatives were deliberately
administered a dose of amn c227 and
briefed on its effects as well as the
dangers of following the feeling of deja
vu should it surface in the field these
infected officers were essentially used
as blood hounds relying on any sense of
unusual familiarity to sniff out new
dens of SCP 939 so they could be
captured and contained by the foundation
as far as we know this operation is
still ongoing today however now that the
foundation has a sufficient number of
specimens to study additional dens of
scp-939 that are discovered are ordered
to be immediately destroyed as for the
scp-939 still in captivity they are
contained in an environmentally
regulated and negatively pressured cells
with walls of reinforced concrete the
doors to the cells are airtight to
prevent the leakage of any amn
c227 and any Personnel that interact
with one of the creatures is required to
wear level C Hazmat gear to avoid
exposure and follow decontamination
procedures upon exiting the cell all SCP
939 have subdermal tracking devices
implanted to find them in the event of
Escape only one SCP 939 has given birth
in the time that the creatures have been
in captivity strangely scp-939 young
look indistinguishable from Human
infants and change their physical
appearance at some yet unknown Point as
they age if any more offspring are
produced they will immediately be
separated from the parent and studied
all that we know is that they are found
in caves in the woods outside of a small
town it could be any Town even yours so
if you're ever out hiking and struck
with a sudden feeling of deja vu don't
investigate don't get curious just go
home it might just save your life in a
remote part of Russia a mysterious
disease outbreak was tearing through a
tiny farming village with terrifying
side effects there was no cure no clue
to where it came from and worst of all
the disease's terrifying impact didn't
end with death no it was after those
carrying the disease died that the real
Horrors started after an agonizing fever
that leaves the victims writhing in pain
they quickly succumb to the disease only
to rise from their graves to wreck havoc
on the living the virus continues to
spread until the corpses outnumber those
trying to hide from them as the world
spirals into almost certain ruin it
sounds like the plot of a zombie movie
but for the SCP Foundation this is
anything but fiction and the terror that
unfolded in that little Siberian town is
the first recorded encounter with SCP
610 also known as the flesh that hates
first livestock began to vanish from
farms theft wild animals were suspected
but no suspects could be found and no
mutilated remains turned up the animals
weren't being stolen and they weren't
being eaten so what happened to them
with no more animals Left to Lose the
farmers themselves then began to
disappear but the authorities refused to
take the missing person's cases
seriously the missing Farmers families
would contact the police make a report
and then the whole thing was forgotten
it was written off just as another
unsolved disappearance which wasn't
uncommon in the wild and unforgiving
region then the police themselves began
to disappear the families of the missing
Farmers would sometimes report strange
sounds from the surrounding Woods
describing moans and inhuman screeches
of pain one young boy reported seeing a
cow with what he described as tentacles
lurking around the edge of the trees
Regional Police were dispatched to the
location and ordered to investigate and
report back on their finding ings within
24 hours but the units sent to the area
didn't report back and were never heard
from again upon learning of the reports
the Russian government grew increasingly
concerned fearing domestic Insurgency or
foreign Espionage of some kind could be
at play they sent a small team of
special agents to the area and one by
one those agents disappeared just like
the others before them it seemed no one
who went into the village after the
disappearances started ever came out
again they had all simply vanished
desperate for answers the Russian
government contacted the only people in
the world who could help the SCP
Foundation what the foundation found
over the course of their investigation
would shock and unnerve them going
beyond anything they had previously
discovered before the investigation
officially began the affected area was
sealed off by the Russian government not
knowing if it would be safe to send
researchers into the containment
perimeter the foundation set up a small
cameram mounted unit nicknamed Herby to
capture footage of whatever remained of
the village the images captured by Herby
revealed what exactly had become of the
people in this doomed Village and the
true nightmarish nature of SCP
610 SCP 610 is a ker class entity
meaning it's an anomaly that's
exceedingly difficult to contain
consistently or reliably with
containment procedures often being
extensive and complex 610 is a highly
contagious skin disease that initially
manifests like an ordinary allergic
reaction
with symptoms including increased
sensitivity itching and a rash but
within just 3 hours of those initial
symptoms appearing the rash starts to
turn into masses of Scar Tissue on the
chest and arms these masses spread over
the legs and back of the victim and
completely consume them in thick rubbery
flesh within 5 hours once they're
covered the victim will cease all vital
functions unfortunately for them and
doubly so for those around them they do
not stay Dead about 3 minutes after
expiring ing the victim's vitals will
restart at a heightened rate and the
masses of Flesh encasing their body will
begin to move and multiply mutating them
into a form beyond anything resembling
the human they once were the specific
type of mutation varies from case to
case but as included the head becoming
massive in bulbous the growth of extra
limbs and in especially gruesome cases
the victim's body splitting apart to
allow extra tendrils of Flesh to sprout
from the open wound occasionally an
infected person will stop moving and
become rooted to the ground in a set
location once it is settled their flesh
will spread itself across the ground
encasing all nearby objects in flaps of
scar tissue the infected that maintain
their Mobility are highly aggressive
even violent and will attempt to infect
any living thing that comes into their
line of sight the disease does not only
infect humans and can take over any
living organism within a matter of hours
due to the highly contagious and
dangerous nature of the disease safe
observation of infected specimens and
areas is only possible with drones and
mounted cameras this brings us back to
Herby the first such mounted camera to
record footage of the infected area
Herby was deployed to an infection site
also known as site a without any damage
remained at the outside perimeter of the
village for 2 hours observing several
infected humans and fire damage to many
of the homes before following an
infected into an intact house Herby's
camera feed captured the infected person
entering the house and sitting down at
the table table inside there were
several other infected humans in the
house and one unidentified infected
creature that remained immobile under
the table after viciously assaulting one
of the other infected humans the
infected returned to the table and began
to lay out plates on top of it pieces of
its flesh began to wriggle and tear away
from its body before settling onto each
plate once the plates were filled the
infected sitting at the table began to
grab at the Flesh and crush it into
their mouths in a perverse imitation of
a normal Meal Time Gathering after
capturing this stomach churning display
Herby left the house and continued to
explore the village the recorded footage
of a large stack of bodies that seemed
to be made up of both Russian military
and civilians with an infected sitting
on top as Herby maneuvered towards the
remains of the Town Hall an infected
grabbed the Rover off the ground Herby's
camera was able to capture the face of
the infected that grabbed the Rover the
face was that of a young girl around 10
years old strangely intact at top a
large distorted body the final moments
of Herby's camera feed captured the
infected girl's face bursting open
revealing tendrils of Flesh that pulled
Herby into the gaping mall then the feed
cut to Black Herby was regarded as lost
but the video feed briefly resumed 5
hours later showing the camera covered
with an unidentified slime after this
the video feed was cut for good and
Herby abandoned in site a the foundation
has sent several manned Expeditions into
site a where many Expedition forces have
fallen victim to the infected several
operatives were also lost in an
earthquake that revealed a network of
underground tunnels a man Expedition
into these tunnels was attempted and the
video feed that was captured by the
researchers on the expedition was deeply
disturbing there were images of an
abandoned church filled with infected
and a mass of uninfected or partially
infected human captives the final
moments of the video feed from this
Expedition captured several operatives
being murdered by an infected human
wielding a farming Scythe indicating
that the infected are capable of using
simple Weaponry in addition to Brute
Force the use of this weapon paired with
the presence of captives in the
underground tunnels paints a terrifying
picture of the kind of organization the
infected are capable of no more man
Expeditions have been attempted or if
they have they have been highly
classified ordinarily once a new SCP is
discovered it is placed in containment
at the foundation with special
procedures in place so that it can be
studied or even neutralized in the rare
occasions where it's deemed necessary
when it comes to SCP 610 though
containment might just be impossible it
simply covers too much area and is too
dangerous to expose to human researchers
instead all infected areas have been
isolated with the permission of the
Russian government there is an official
perimeter established around these areas
and any civilians that approach them are
told to leave under the pretense of
ongoing military operations for once a
top secret military project is the more
innocent answer armed guards are placed
at the perimeter of every infected area
and any living thing with symptoms of
SCP 610 spotted near the perimeter is to
be immobilized killed and burned from as
far away as possible any living thing
that comes in contact with SCP 610
whether a soldier a scientist or a
civilian is immediately terminated and
their remains destroyed if someone comes
within 3 m of an infected organism they
will be quarantined and remotely
examined to determine if if they have
been infected while the spread of SCP
610 can be airborne it has been
determined to be far less contagious
when spread through air particles as
opposed to physical contact the
infection sites remain active to this
day like modern-day leper colonies
though they are isolated from the
general population and the military is
doing everything in their power to
contain the infected SCP 610 is still
very much alive it is rare for an entity
to exist that the foundation cannot
truly Ain but can only try to guard
against and that makes this infection
all the more terrifying who knows how
much it has mutated over the years
growing spreading hungry for new hosts
there is still so much that the
foundation does not know about the flesh
that hates such as how it works what it
can do or even where it came from since
the origin of the first infection is
still at this point entirely unknown it
has shown itself to be capable of
learning planning and protecting itself
so who is to say that it couldn't figure
out a way to escape from its isolated
area it is so highly contagious and
spreads so quickly that just one tiny
infected rabbit and one inattentive
soldier could be enough for SCP 610 to
reach the general population if it did
its violent destructive nature and
hatred for all life would mean that
everything not just the people but
animals plants and the world itself
could be at risk
and no one is ready for this kind of
infection a disease that turns the human
body against itself turns our skin into
a weapon and a tomb stripping away
identity humanity and everything that
isn't made of the same hateful flesh so
let's hope that the perimeter holds and
the next time you feel a little itchy
try not to think about what might happen
next it was late October of 1993 and
John Matthews of Myrtle Beach South
Carolina Ina had just scored a date with
Sarah one of the most popular girls in
school and he had planned the perfect
night out for the two of them a haunted
house had just been set up in town and
he like many guys before him figured he
could use that as a chance to impress
his date he' already been through the
attraction so he knew exactly when to
put his arm around Sarah when one of the
costume actors or animatronics tried to
spook them if any of them got too close
for comfort he might even punch them
just to show Sarah How brave he was that
would be a Surefire way to impress any
girl however Jon had no idea of the real
horror that waited for him and his day
through the doors of this seemingly
normal fun house at first the haunted
house went as normal John laughed at all
the fake cobwebs and plastic skeletons
making sure Sarah knew how dumb he
thought they looked he shoved away
actors dressed as AE murderers and told
them to stay away from his date it was
dark so they couldn't really see each
other's faces but John guessed that
Sarah was probably really impressed all
in all the date was going well until
they got to a room that John hadn't seen
the first time he'd been through it
seemed like it had been added overnight
but at the same time it didn't MH with
the theme the theme of the haunted house
this year was cannibal hotel but this
room looked more like Dracula's castle
complete with actors dressed as
Frankenstein The Wolf Man and Dracula
himself one of them was even a Dead
Ringer for the actor Vincent Price John
and Sarah watched confused as the actors
performed their routines which just like
their surroundings seemed out of place
it was total Hackney full of lame puns
and very basic scares though the special
effects were undeniably impressive when
Jon and Sarah walked through the room
the actor dressed as Dracula stood in
front of Jon and started pretending to
hypnotize him up close he did look a lot
like Bella legosi the actor who'
portrayed the count during his first big
screen appearance this definitely threw
Jon off a little but unfortunately this
Dracula didn't have legosi's acting
talents you are under my control Dracula
said waving his fingers at Jon and
staring at him John getting really sick
of this pushed the guy out of the way to
move on to the next room but when he did
he felt that something was really really
wrong here he practically dragged Sarah
away from watching The Wolf Man
transform and ran the rest to the way
through the house all of his bravado now
gone Sarah asked her date what was wrong
and he didn't tell her how could he
without sounding crazy when he had
touched that actor playing Dracula
something hadn't felt right even through
his suit and Cape John had been able to
tell that something was wrong he was
cold and rigid not like a human being
but like a robot or a wax dummy this is
just one of multiple complaints from
Halloween attractions around the United
States that prompted the action of of
the SCP Foundation several witnesses
described either seeing people that
resembled classic movie Monsters or
living wax models of those monsters
appearing in various haunted houses corn
mazes carnivals and strip malls across
the country the foundation has
designated this troop of hammy wax
actors SCP
4153 during performances SCP 4153 use
wax to alter their appearance produce
props including fake blood and gore and
even manipulate blackx objects from afar
while this results in some uncanny
special effects the content of the
performances tend to be pretty standard
classic haunted house Fair they mostly
do things like reenacting scenes from
classic horror films and telling spooky
jokes with a little fake blood here and
there when the foundation arrived at the
Myrtle Beach attraction they apprehended
the various wax characters and
determined that their Eerie resemblance
to the classic horror characters wasn't
just makeup after the horrors some of
these Foundation employees had seen on
on the job living wax models of
Frankenstein's monster and Dracula
seemed almost cute in comparison and the
troop of wax actors were taken to site 9
for questioning and containment the
first member of the troop to be
interviewed on site was Dracula dubs CP
4153 d017 by the foundation he was
interviewed by agent Timothy West who
was totally unimpressed with Dracula
shtick he tried to hypnotize agent West
an act which he flatly refused to
indulge in Dracula provided the aent
with seemingly no useful information
only responding to questions with
cliches like we were all dead the whole
time and the log was coming from inside
the house the next wax figure to be
interrogated was Frankenstein's monster
AKA SCP 4153
d015 it was interviewed by agent
Samantha henwick much like how SCP 4153
017 stayed fully in character as Dracula
during his interview scp4 31
53-15 seemed to really believe that he
was actor Boris carof who played
Frankenstein's monster in the
1930s the SCP spoke in an exact
imitation of Carlo's voice and speech
patterns and talked to agent henwick as
if she was another actor on a movie set
he talked about how honored he was to be
part of the project and asked are we
rolling when he noticed the conversation
was being recorded agent Henrik
responded to the scp's comments with
confusion a fact which he told to mean
that she was staying in character like a
true actor he took a moment to prepare
himself before pulling his own head off
much to the horror of agent henwick the
last and probably most interesting of
the interviews conducted in 1993 was
with the wax figure who resembled
Vincent Price more specifically Vincent
Price in his role as Henry Jared in
1953's House of Wax a movie about a mad
sculptor who made wax figures out of the
corpses of his victims this wax Max
figure was designated SCP
415336 and was interviewed by agent
Gerald Penn Penn started the interview
with a simple question why do you try to
frighten people SCP
415336 had an equally simple answer why
does anyone try to frighten it's fun to
be frightened almost as much fun as it
is to do the
frightening Penn was skeptical pointing
out that the wax figures act wasn't
especially frightening the SCP laughed
as isely telling pen to have some
respect for the classics pen was still
not having any of it he had been with
the SCP Foundation for 20 years at this
point and he'd seen enough Real Horror
that the so-called Classics had no
effect on him whatsoever he pressured
price for answers but instead of
responding with a straight answer price
launched into a speech about his
feelings on
Monsters he said you'll call any o with
a steak knife hunting gaggles of teens
and monsters these days there's no wit
no humor no charm where's the passion
the artisanship where's the sense of
theater would you like to know something
peculiar I've almost never played a
monster well I've played villains most
certainly but not monsters only men
besieged by Fate driven to Revenge still
I've always had a fondness for them even
as a child I sympathize more with the
monster than the hero agent pen who at
this point was really getting tired of
all the theatric started to interject
but when he opened his mouth to speak he
was only able to get a few words out
before his tongue went numb and rigid in
his mouth he could no longer move it
agent Penn tried to speak but his tongue
was too solid and heavy to do anything
more than knock uselessly against his
bottom teeth he felt something dislodge
inside his mouth and he hoped maybe it
was the feeling of his tongue being
freed from whatever spell the SCP had
put it under but then he started to feel
a tearing and a sticky heaviness in his
bottom jaw agent pen reached up and felt
around inside his mouth he started to
scream indistinctly when he realized to
his horror that his tongue had ripped
off he pulled it out of his mouth and
when he held it in his hand his fears
were confirm somehow it had become
nothing more than a lump of pink wax now
completely tongass agent pen continued
to babble frantically no doubt trying to
curse at the wax creature sitting in
front of him SCP
415336 finally paid attention to his
interviewer's distress at this point he
turned to agent Penn with a look of
disapproval and disappointment and said
oh dear your tongue seems to have gotten
away from you there here allow me the
SCP leaned towards agent Penn and though
the agent wanted to resist he found that
he could no longer move his arms in fact
his whole body had gone numb and rigid
just like the wax tongue the only
movement he was capable of was opening
his mouth in the wax fimile of Vincent
Price started molding his tongue back to
the proper shape and reattached it
inside agent Penn's mouth agent Penn
whimpered unable to do anything while
the scp's hands were in his mouth the
creature said hash now I warned you
about this I told you that you mustn't
disturb the wax before it hardens that
is a crucial part of the process it
needs to solidify otherwise you risk
disturbing the performance by the time
his tongue was reattached and seal agent
Penn was on the verge of tears he
gurgled gasping for eror wiggling his
tongue around in his mouth to make sure
that it work the SCP returned to his
seat pleased with his own handiwork
Splendid Splendid quit is new now let's
take it from the top shall we agent pen
took a deep breath studying himself as
SCP
415336 whispered the word action pen
resumed the interview with the same
simple question why do you try to
frighten people SCP
415336 gave the same simple answer why
does anyone try to frighten it's fun to
be frightened almost as much fun as it
is to do the frightening the interview
continued for only a few minutes longer
with both parties repeating only things
they'd said earlier in the recording the
log ends with SCP
415336 once again saying have some
respect for the classics not long after
the interview concluded Foundation
management completely lost contact with
site 9 a mobile task force was sent in
to investigate the cause of this loss of
contact and on arrival they found a
catastrophic Containment Breach not a
single member of on-site Personnel was
found alive and strangely all of their
bodies seemed to be coated in wax
further examination revealed that this
initial observation wasn't the case at
all they weren't just coated in wax no
every member of the site 9 team had all
of their major organs including their
skin surgically extracted and replaced
with sculpted wax of course this was
assumed to be the doing of SCP 4153 but
oddly all of the autopsies suggested
that the removal of organs had happened
weeks before the apprehension of SCP
4153 even though all of the on-site
Personnel had seemed alive and well
right up until the Containment Breach
outside of being replaced by Wax no
damage was done to the bodies it seemed
that everyone had just Dr dropped dead
at the same time there was one body that
was different though that of agent
Gerald Penn agent Penn's decapitated
body was found in the same containment
cell that had been used for SCP
415336 next to the body was a photograph
showing SCP
415336 holding up agent Penn's screaming
head and on the back a single sentence
was written from one horror fishion to
another always stay ahead head all of
the SCP 4153 instances remain
unaccounted for an MTF Iota 10 also
known as the dam feds continue to
monitor for new sightings and reports of
activity that may be linked to the wax
troop hopefully one day they'll be taken
into Foundation custody and contained
and maybe all it will take is for them
to meet someone with a sufficient
appreciation for the classics it was the
summer of 2012 in Damascus and for the
people of Syria it it certainly seemed
like all the predictions about the end
of the world were coming true the Syrian
Civil War was raging between multiple
Rebel groups and the dictator Bashar
al-assad whose government was shelling
its own people as well as using chemical
weapons and brutal campaigns of violence
across the country in hopes of quelling
the Rebellion little did they know
amidst all this pain and bloodshed
something even more dangerous was
brewing an anomalous phenomenon in the
the sunny Plains north of Damascus that
may pose a threat to all of humanity
someday a threat known to the SCP
Foundation as SCP
3989 the bone Orchard this temporal and
spatial anomaly was discovered a few
years earlier in 2009 before the Syrian
Civil War even officially began it's
strange for a highly dangerous cclass
anomaly to be discovered under such
seemingly mundane circumstances the SCP
Foundation first became aware of SCP
3989 after a small Olive Orchard owner
sold a strangely high amount of Olives
that shouldn't have been possible when
compared to his reported number of OA
eura olive trees field agents were
dispatched to question the owner about
his sudden success but he was resistant
to questioning the agents began a covert
surveillance operation to figure out
what was actually going on here at which
point they discovered a considerable
spatial anomaly the olive Orchard was
Far bigger on on the inside the property
was seized by the foundation for
containment the owner had no real
knowledge of the spatial anomaly it's
likely he just decided not to look a
gift horse in the mouth while making
money hand over fist from the extra
olives he sold the owner was given
amnestics and a new life as the
foundation began to study this anomaly
which was now labeled SCP
3989 to this day no researcher has been
able to figure out the origin of 3989
anomalous qualities it was first given a
uclid class designation and cordon off
from the public with a simple chain link
fence while Foundation investigations
were underway on the inside on a map the
plot of land the olive Farm should
occupy is about 5 square acres but this
plot contains an unseen portal to a
pocket Dimension within its 12 M active
Zone which doesn't follow the same
spatial laws that our reality does this
subdimension known as SCP
3989 is a hot bed of fast fascinating
anomalous activity upon discovery of
this Hot Zone the foundation established
the nearby area 126 as a research center
and a makeshift containment facility for
any anomalous entities captured from SCP
3989 it seemed like the foundation
really had a handle on this situation
but they were blissfully unaware of the
true Horrors lurking with an SCP 3989
Das a but they'd soon find out in the
most horrifying way possible Dr far
gazelli was assigned to head the
research into the anomalous Zone within
3989 and naturally he began organizing
fact finding Expeditions Into the Heart
of the affected area the first skinny
pig to head into The Hot Zone was former
Foundation agent hosiah herck who'd been
demoted to the lowly d-class position of
d126 D15 due to failures on a previous
Mission with a remote link to Dr gazelli
herck was forced to venture into the
active anomalous Zone to collect footage
and samples of the Laura and fauna
within the first thing herri noticed on
his expedition was the strange quality
of the olive trees within the active
Zone The Bark was a stark white and the
leaves a bloody red up close her could
see that the Trunks and branches of the
trees had undergone a process known as
oifc where the material slowly becomes
bone or bone-like tissue hence the
anomaly's creepy name the bone Orchard
these aifi trees became known as SCP
39891 heric also made a another
Discovery all over the trees and ground
were wormlike creatures that looked like
long maggots that the foundation dobbed
SCP 3989 d1a agent herck then noticed
something was off about the leaves of
the aifi trees they were beating he
looked closer and they appeared to be
heart tissue filled with pumping veins
Dr gazelli ordered herck to take a
branch for testing and when he did the
tree began to bleed when he looked down
he saw that the worm like creatures that
covered the ground were now crawling up
his legs ignoring orders from Dr gazelli
herck fled from the active Zone in
Terror as he left Dr gazelli caught
something in the corner of herrick's
body cam footage a long white hind limb
disappearing behind a tree back in our
normal Dimension tests on the sample her
collected yielded more upsetting
discoveries genetically the trees were
identical to humans the trunks were
human bone and the leaves really were
made of human human heart tissue
fascinated and just a little bit
horrified Dr gazelli authorized further
Expeditions into
3989 this time though agent herck would
be accompanied by another d-class and
both would be armed with handguns and
protective body armor as it would turn
out this Expedition would be even more
horrifying than the first as the two DCL
classes explored the active zones to
collect further samples they found that
the worms were responsible for the
osificante otherwise nonanomalous olive
trees they consumed the wood little by
little and deposited human bone matter
in return her and His companion also
noticed that these trees were beginning
to bear fruit Dr gazelli ordered heric
to collect some of this fruit for
testing but when they attempted to
remove the fruit it burst releasing more
worm creatures it seemed that the
converted trees acted as incubators for
their egg sacks before the duo could
return with the samples they were able
to take the creature that had been
spotted on herrick's body cam during the
first mission finally appeared it was
huge with long white Limbs and no facial
features except for a huge mouth it
grabbed herrick's companion and
literally ate the top half of his body
in a single bite before dropping his
legs to the ground this horrifying Beast
and the many others like it would later
be designated as SCP 3989 d2a heric
pulled out his sidearm and shot the
creature several times the creature
ignored the bullets though and charged
herck the feed from his body cam cut out
soon after both men were declared killed
in action and in recognition of his
sacrifice Josiah herck was posthumously
reinstated to his old position in the
foundation job well done agent Dr
gazelli meanwhile prepared for the next
mission this time knowing of the clear
dangers present within the bone Orchard
Dr gazelli recruited the help of MTF
Zeta 9 aka the mle rats three members
referred to as Charlie team were sent
into the anomalous Zone once again
remotely directed by Dr gazelli they
were equipped with experimental
ultrasound technology so they could scan
the fruit of the trees within
3989 without breaking any and incurring
the wrath of 3989 d2a which seemed to
act as centuries for the trees early on
in their Journey they found the body of
agent herck crucified against one of the
aifi trees his skin covered in
mysterious symbols that were likely of
saric origin while we don't have time to
fully explore sarcasm that will require
a video explanation all of its own all
you need to know is that it's a
dangerous religious cult that worships
flesh and disease and has close ties to
similar dangerous anomalies like SCP 610
also known as the flesh that hates
people familiar with that SCP will note
eerily strange similarities to some of
the things the mole rats were about to
encounter as Charlie team explored they
saw a huge number of 3989 2A observing
them with eyeless faces from between the
aifi trees they pressed on until they
discovered what seemed to be an entirely
new kind of tree within the bone Orchard
SCP 3989 D2 were huge trees made out of
what appears to be enlarged human spines
in place of a trunk the smaller Twigs on
the tree were made from heart and lung
tissue and the whole thing was covered
in what appeared to be human amniotic
sacks Charlie team attempted to use
their ultrasound scanners to discover
the contents of these sacks but one of
them exploded in the process releasing
an entirely new variety of monster from
the Sachs emerged the larvel stage of
SCP 3989 d2b smaller humanoid monsters
with no faces No sensory organs two
pelvises four legs and an exposed spine
suddenly Charlie team could feel a
horrifying saric presence around around
them which one member of the team
described as being like someone grabbing
her liver and giggling in her face as
the various Monsters of the bone Orchard
began to converge on the team the voice
of the saric prophet of War and the hunt
Oro began sounding in their ears he was
beckoning them to join him while Charlie
team fled from the active Zone Dr
gazelli felt increasingly drawn into it
he heard the voice of Oro and he liked
what he heard little by little the
workers of Area 1 26 were losing their
minds manipulated by the saric power of
the bone orchard right next to them day
after day they were no longer loyal to
the foundation they wanted to serve
their new Dark Masters the fourth and
final expedition was led by Dr gazelli
himself he took a band of loyal
followers and one non-believer on a
quest into the active Zone to find an
orchan Temple they believed was hidden
in the very heart of the bone Orchard
once they were inside
gazeli and his loyalists murdered the
non-believer as a sacrifice to their new
master They carried on until they
eventually found what they were looking
for a giant Stone Temple resembling an
Aztec zigurat dubbed SCP 3989 D4 there
they also encountered a new kind of
monster dubbed SCP
39893 these beasts were larger than the
others and resembled ancient warriors
they had insect-like exoskeleton armor
horned heads additional Hind and
forelimbs and integrated bladed weapons
what Dr gazelli and his companions
thought would be paradise turned out to
be a kind of hell as they were led into
the temple where temporal and spatial
distortions broke their mind and the
multiple highly aggressive instances of
SCP
39893 d2a and -2b broke their bodies the
whole thing had been a horrifying trap
in that moment back at area 126 another
fleshy horrifying tree sprouted out of
the ground in the middle of the complex
monsters that had once been Dr gazelli
and his followers emerged from its
amniotic Sachs and all hell broke loose
throughout the complex soon enough the
base was crawling with monsters from the
bone Orchard and staff who' become
brainwashed saric cultists working in
service of Oro humans were gathered up
to be sacrificed to the ever growing
number of anomalous trees
things came to a head when the anomaly
in area 126 was visited by an outside
agent from the foundation working on
behalf of the Hazardous Materials
containment liaison biological
containment specialist Dr Marshall Grant
and his team arrived at the site and
were horrified to see the saric
nightmare that had unfolded they quickly
engaged in a firefight with the
anomalous creatures and saric devotees
who'd gained control over area 126 a
number of Dr Grant's team were lost in
the process but thankfully they were
able to eventually regain control of the
base and the anomalous area after this
incident SCP 3989 was upgraded to ker
class and given a huge upgrade in
security including 4 M High concrete
walls and a platoon siiz Regiment of
mobile task force members with heavy
Weaponry the force that took over the
minds of those exposed was designated
SCP
39895 a force so powerful that those
infected are given the choice to self
self terminate or be contained forever
this may seem like a somewhat happy
ending to a grim Tale But one detail
keeps Dr Grant and everyone at the
foundation who is forced to deal with
3989 awake at night according to all
recent studies into the bone Orchard it
isn't contained at all in fact the
active zone is getting bigger nowhere is
more secure than an SCP Foundation
facility they make Fort Knox look like a
revolving door with a spare key under
the mat that's why when someone or
something can infiltrate without even
being noticed it's considered a major
threat and doing exactly that is what
put a mysterious group of insurgents
known as the Serpent's hand on the map
but this group of Interest isn't just
famous for its ability to sneak into
Foundation strongholds like a lot of the
SCP foundation's biggest threats from
the Scarlet King to the chaos Insurgency
the root roots of the Serpent's hand are
closer than they think the foundation's
first official brush with the Serpent's
hand came shortly after they contained
SCP 268 an Irish Tweed wool news boy cap
believed to have been created sometime
in the 1800s the only identifying mark
on the cap is a label with the following
phrase written in Middle Irish the
garden is the Serpent's Place initially
believed to be a reference to the
serpent in the biblical Garden of Eden
this uclid class SC p is a double-edged
sword it gives the user a useful
Supernatural ability at a terrifying
Supernatural cost anyone wearing the cap
appears so utterly unremarkable that
nobody is able to take notice of them
and when they leave a person's general
area of awareness they're quickly
forgotten the user isn't invisible but
they might as well be if you're a person
whose line of work involves sneaking and
subterfuge or if you're just a major
introvert this sounds like a dream
coming true however like a lot of
anomalies this dream can quickly become
a nightmare if someone wears the cap
repeatedly or for too long at one time
they risk the effects of the cap
becoming permanent even when it's
removed you can become a forgotten
person impossible to notice and remember
even to those closest to you why anyone
would want such a fade is a mystery so
it came as a surprise to the foundation
when the Hat suddenly disappeared from
cure containment replaced by a note
reading thanks I needed my hat back LS
who was this mysterious LS and was the
anomaly truly theirs prior to
containment scientists security
officials and administrators hoped this
would be an isolated incident but LS was
far from done and even worse for the
foundation LS was now armed with a
perfect anomalous tool to make their
next Containment Breach even smoother
the next incident was known as security
breach incident x23 and was committed
against the extremely valuable site 19
the largest Foundation site there is
most humiliating of all for the
foundation security team working there
security footage indicated that LS
simply strolled into the base without
being noticed SCP 268 was working
wonders this time LS had a new Target
SCP 914 an anomalous machine also known
as the Clockworks this machine
originally tested by the famously
emotionalist Dr Charles gears has the
ability to refine any object placed into
its Chambers into a greater version of
their original selves often with strange
and anomalous results you can probably
see why someone wanting to utilize
anomalies for their own gain would take
such a keen interest in this one LS
breeed past the guards inexplicably
destroyed the file for SCP 407 a taped
song that causes unchecked cellular
growth and made their way towards
914 unfortunately a researcher who was
working on 914 was murdered by LS during
the breach we have no idea what they did
with 914 perhaps they refined 268 to act
as an even more effective stealth tool
without its unpleasant side effects
maybe they made the daring move of
refining thems we'll never know all we
do know is at this time LS left a letter
it was long rambling and Phil opical
with no incriminating information that
could be used to identify the mysterious
figure they signed off the letter with I
leave you with one final truth the
garden is the Serpent's place the
divinities of fear and Order who come to
walk in the cool evening air are only
visitors do not fail to see the evil
hiding in the light nor the aromatic
beauty of the palest flower of Darkness
signed sincerely LS these repeat
repeated references to the serpent clude
the foundation in on the affiliation of
this new Troublemaker a growing group of
Interest named The Serpent's hand but
really who are the Serpent's hand what
do they want what is their connection to
other active groups of Interest like the
chaos Insurgency and the global code
Coalition and was this mysterious LS
figure the leader of the group or just
another agent these were all the
questions on the minds of the
foundation's best and brightest tactical
thinkers but the answers didn't come
easy during the Serpent's hands
investigations the foundation found an
unlikely Ally in what is usually one of
their biggest opponents the global
occult Coalition the GOC had dealt with
the Serpent's hand before and understood
their Central philosophy whereas the
foundation and the GOC were both
committed to acting in secret and
maintaining a sense of normality the
Serpent's hand wanted the exact opposite
they wanted to destroy the secrecy
around on the anomalous and Supernatural
and reveal the existence of it all to
the general public while the foundation
and the GOC think this is crazy the
Serpent's hand aren't just insane
architects who want to unleash chaos
across the world in fact they actually
have some pretty interesting points the
Serpent's hand acknowledges that the
supernatural can be dangerous but much
like natural disasters and crime will
the public benefit from not knowing
about them members of the Serpent's hand
also fight for the rights of non violent
anomalous entities particularly sentient
and Sapient beings they find the
foundation's habit of containing them
and the goc's habit of Killing Them
barbaric and will openly use and
collaborate with anomalies to further
their goals like how LS is a keen
operator of 268 for their infiltration
Missions at least 177 individuals
belonging to the Serpent's hand have
been identified many of which who have
actively performed raids on Foundation
sites AC across the globe it was a
mystery to the foundation how such a
small number of members could run rings
around them and seemingly be everywhere
at once until a revelation was delivered
by the global aod Coalition the
Serpent's hand have an informal
headquarters and an anomalous location
known as The Wanderer Library an ancient
and seemingly Limitless archive
containing every book from every
dimension in the Multiverse this
location exists outside of space and
time and can be accessed through a
global network of interdimensional
portals known as the ways like a
supernatural Guerilla Soldier members of
the Serpent's hand would exit from one
of the ways raid a foundation or gooc
site and then Escape back into another
one of the ways using the wanderer's
library as a safe Zone the library was a
convenient way to access and steal from
sites worldwide with impunity increasing
their stock of anomalous items and
beings each time while performing raids
and stealing anomalies feel like
textbook chaos Insurgency Behavior the
Serpent's hand have an extremely Frosty
relationship with the Insurgency too
often seeing them as greedy erratic and
shortsighted the Serpent's hand has a
series of catchy nicknames for its
various foes it refers to the foundation
as the jailers the go as the book
burners and the chaos Insurgency as the
Madmen the foundation even formed a new
task force known as the bookworms
explicitly for hand related missions
while the foundation has engaged in a
number of raids and skirmishes on the
Serpent's hand since their Feud began
they've never been able to gather any
information about who gives the orders
only the global aote Coalition have been
able to successfully perform a raid on
the wanderer's library an act that was
extremely difficult and costly it also
earned the geoca spot as the Serpent's
hands Public Enemy Number One a role the
foundation isn't eager to take from them
with the UNL limited knowledge present
in The Wanderer library and the
Mysterious nature of their command
structure this group manages to be a
formidable enemy for the foundation
despite its small size what the
foundation doesn't know is that there
actually is no command structure for the
Serpent's hand they're a decentralized
group of Splinter cells and lone wolves
acting out a philosophy rather than a
specific Mission this way of working is
so alien to the highly regimented
structures of the foundation and the GOC
it's no surprise that they're stumped by
it this still leaves us with one more
question Central to the whole mystery if
not the leader of this organization who
exactly is LS to answer this we must
return once more to Dr Charles Ogden
gears the cold and robotic Foundation
scientist in charge of SCP 9914 research
if all the ways Dr gears has been
described so far has made you think he
wouldn't be a particularly warm and
loving father you'd be absolutely right
right just ask his estranged daughter
Allison Chow Allison never forgave gears
for abandoning her and her mother and
she now does everything she can to get
revenge on him and his precious
Foundation but here's the problem the
gears of this Dimension is not the only
one who has a child with an axe to grind
gears has been a dead be dad in a number
of Dimensions so much so that these
disgruntled daughters converge in the
wanders library to plot their Revenge
across Dimensions to together this
Collective of Allison Chows sometimes
believed to just be one Allison is known
to the foundation as the black queen
however they themselves more commonly
refer to their daughter support group
turned terrorist organization as the
little sisters or if you'd prefer the
abbreviation
LS while the Serpent's hand has no
leader the little sisters are some of
its most devoted and dangerous Warriors
they're intelligent coordinated and due
to their obsession with Dr gears
personally invested in hitting the
foundation where it hurts after all
that's what the Serpent's hand is all
about striking out against the
oppressors who keep a strangle hold on
the truth throwing off the chains
imposed by the foundation and the
violence visited upon anomalies by the
global aold Coalition if the Serpent's
hand gets their way one day there may be
a glorious world where humans and
anomalies knowingly coexist it is a nice
thing to imagine utopian even but the
foundation's greatest concern about the
Serpent's hand isn't that they're evil
it is that they're naive while the
Serpent's hand don't wish to usher in
the apocalypse it doesn't mean they
won't by complete accident their
kindness and understanding towards
anomalies May one day make them a
perfect band of useful idiots for an
entity with far darker intentions and
and one day they may just release
something that would really be better
locked away there was nothing out of the
ordinary about Timmy Mason like a lot of
healthy 8-year-old boys Timmy liked to
go on little adventures in and around
his neighborhood and now that summer
vacation had finally rolled around he
had more time than ever to explore but
during one particularly hot day Timmy
suddenly realized that he was exhausted
the heat was beginning to get to him and
he'd forgotten to pack a water bottle
all he had was a couple of dollars and a
handful of quarters rattling around in
his pocket he was considering heading to
a nearby corner store and purchasing a
drink when he first heard the music it
was a tinny rendition of Pop Goes the
Weasel playing in The Distance
underscored by the rumbling of an engine
Timmy's face lit up this could only mean
one thing an ice cream truck just in
time he ran in the direction of the
sounds not wanting to miss out on the
cool sweet relief from the intense
summer heat but when the ice cream truck
suddenly rounded a corner and came into
view Timmy felt a Pang of anxiety it
didn't look like most of the ice cream
trucks he had seen driving around his
neighborhood in Prior Summers it was
shotty an older more boxy model with
peeling white paint but it was so hot
out that Timmy felt he couldn't afford
to be picky if he wanted to cool off the
ice cream truck came to a noisy stop and
Timmy ran over when he reached the side
of the truck he noticed some other
strange details there was no serving
hatch in the back of the truck the
closest thing was a thin dark groove cut
into the driver's side door a door that
seemed almost drawn onto the side of the
truck rather than a door that looked
like it could actually open how could
the driver get in and adding to the
strangeness there was no menu on the
truck either typically on your friendly
neighborhood ice cream truck you'd find
a colorful collection of all the frozen
treats you could buy along with how much
they'd cost you but not here Timmy G
nervously he knew something was wrong
here but for some reason he couldn't
seem to pull himself away he cleared his
throat forced a polite smile and said
can I get a green popsicle please there
was a strange rumbling noise inside the
ice cream truck suddenly the slot in the
door opened a little wider and a long
green popsicle and a plastic wrapper
emerged it came with a small piece of
paper with
$5.75 in loose scratchy handwriting on
it Timmy regarded the note with
suspicion and said that he was sorry but
he didn't have
$5.75 something inside the truck began
rumbling again louder this time more
aggressive while the truck growled from
within Timmy noticed something else was
wrong his popsicle was no ordinary
popsicle it was a dead snake
straightened out and frozen solid Timmy
screamed and dropped the so-called
popsicle he turned and began to run but
it was already too late the slot behind
him yawned open fully and a rusty
spring-loaded chain fired out like a
harpoon on the end of this chain was a
large snapping bear trap which quickly
latched onto Timmy's left leg the chain
yanked and pulled him backwards dragging
him ever closer to the darkened crevice
in the truck door moments later he was
pulled inside and the hatch closed
behind him his screams were muffled and
then overpowered entirely by the
rumbling within soon after there was
silence and finally the cheerful tune of
Pop ghost the weasel began to play once
more the truck drove away prepared to
serve its frozen Delights to another
child somewhere anywhere not long after
Timmy was reported missing another young
boy bought a scoop of strawberry ice
cream and a waffle cone from the same
truck the boy's mother was horrified to
find that this alleged ice cream was
full of what seemed like blood and raw
meat lab test later confirmed that this
gory ice cream was a perfect genetic
match for poor missing Timmy Mason it
didn't take long for the SCP Foundation
to get involved seeing as mysterious
horrifying deaths like this one were
often the first sign of an anomaly's
presence in the area and they were able
to quickly track down and isolate the
Rogue ice cream truck this wasn't
especially difficult for the agents
assigned to the case since it literally
announced its presence with loud
obnoxious music well it was easy to find
the ice cream truck soon designated SCP
1386 did however prove to be more
difficult to contain than they first
imagined when a mobile task force
attempted to engage the truck in hopes
of apprehending it an earsplitting siren
began to blast from the truck's
undercarriage this caused catastrophic
interior damage to everyone involved
incidentally it's now believed that the
reason the ice cream truck engaged in
this defensive Behavior had nothing to
do with the fact the mobile task force
was armed but rather because of what
they weren't carrying it appears that
SCP 1386 doesn't turn on its siren
because of danger but when it detects
that someone is approaching it who isn't
carrying any money eventually the
foundation was able to trick the ice
cream truck into containment luring it
into a fake walled off neighborhood
where it could drive its rounds
constantly without the risk of
encountering civilians all those who had
previous encounters with the ice cream
truck were given amnestic treatment and
SCP 1386 was finally officially
contained but while it had been taken
off the streets the foundation's work
was only just beginning it was time for
research to commence the first key
discoveries that aided in the
investigation involve the factors that
are required for SCP 1386 to even serve
its subjects in the first place as the
previously mentioned mobile task force
learned you need to approach the truck
with at least $20 in cash to be
absolutely sure that it won't turn your
ears inside out the truck also proves to
be extremely Adept at reading human
emotions and refuses to serve anyone who
doesn't appear happy with these
requirements now known the foundation
felt prepared to finally make some
orders first they sent in a pair of
level three researchers each of them
requested a delicious cookies and cream
flavored smoothie the truck pushed both
Smoothies Out of the slot in its store
one marked with the letter M and the
other with the letter g a handwritten
receipt with a price of
$4.89 written on it they paid the price
and the transaction ended without
incident the smoothies were apparently
pretty good too next one of the
researchers returned perhaps longing for
another taste of SCP 1386 is wonderful
ice cream this time he requested a
Neapolitan ice cream sandwich the truck
rumbled for a moment before dispensing
what seemed to be a ham and cheese
sandwich with slices of tomato however
upon taking a bite out of the sandwich
the researcher found that this was
actually just a perfect replica of a ham
and cheese sandwich made from Neapolitan
ice cream the receipt released from the
slot simply said April Fool's before the
truck drove away without even asking for
any payment the same researcher would
return to the ice cream truck one more
time this time requesting a single scoop
of vanilla ice cream in a waffle cone it
was provided to him without issue and he
happily paid the 72 cents the truck
requested in return the next test
wouldn't go quite as swimmingly by which
we mean it caused a horrifying death
this time a slightly more senior
researcher wanted to perform a test on
the ice cream truck he asked for a peach
flavored push pop which he received
without issue however when he refused to
pay the price an admittedly steep
$16 all hell broke loose as he tried to
walk away the hatch opened a full 6 ft
releasing its large rusty metal trap
around the senior researcher he was
pulled into the truck followed by a
horrific rumbling noise not long after
the slot began to spew a stream of pink
liquid for a Solid 5 minutes before
driving away this pink puree was later
proven to be a genetic match to the
researcher after this the foundation
refused to allow any other researchers
to interact with SCP 1386 only d-class
Personnel would be permitted to take
part in the tests in contrast to the
senior researchers horrifying death the
d-class Personnel seemed to get along
extremely well with SCP
1386 the first d-class asked for a
cherry popsicle with nuts the truck
produced an unwrapped Cherry popsicle
with nuts embedded in the ice along with
a receipt reading
$22.20 your nuts the d-class chuckled as
he read the receipt and paid the truck
without incident the second d-class
requested a more esoteric treat a Caesar
salad flavor popsicle however the ice
cream truck isn't one to back down from
a challenge It produced an off- green
popsicle that tasted like quote lightly
dressed lettuce with a hint of croutons
the next d-class ordered a dark
chocolate fudge pop but wasn't able to
pay an exact change he gave the truck $2
bills and was given a carefully wrapped
package with a crude drawing of US
currency on the front when the package
was opened he saw that it contained the
exact change he required down to the
penny he made an official request to the
foundation to keep the change but his
request was denied the foundation then
pushed its d-class Personnel to ask for
more complex constructions just to see
what SCP 1386 was capable of the next
d-class asked for a Kinder Surprise egg
the kind which are banned in the US due
to their history as being a choking
hazard however the ice cream truck
didn't have a hard time constructing the
egg except this one was made out of ice
cream rather than chocolate it did seem
beyond the truck's capability to create
the toy inside instead including a small
piece of paper reading i o you one toy
the next interaction wasn't quite as
cordial the d-class requested one Cherry
ice Lolly one Cherry ice pop one Cherry
popsicle and one cherry flavored drink
frozen this resulted in the ice cream
truck making a horrifying noise
described as being like someone skinning
a cat in Reverse it then unceremoniously
ejected the Red Ice causing it to
shatter on the ground before releasing a
styrofoam cup filled with frozen green
liquid this liquid was shown to contain
huge quantities of arsenic but was
thankfully impossible to drink on
account of the fact that its melting
point is so high that it it's impossible
to liquefy with current technology and
our current knowledge of SCP 1386
testing ends with its strangest story of
all a non-verbal d-class was instructed
to write his order on a piece of paper
to pass to the truck in hopes of seeing
if it would respond to written commands
a slot opened up in the door a few
inches lower than the usual slot and a
thin flesh colored appendage slithered
out its hand a kind of two-fingered
pincher it took the note from the
d-class and gave him him an ice cream
cone in return the declass was visibly
disturbed by the hand saying that it
looked horrifying and smelled like death
he even refused to eat the ice cream
saying that he'd lost his appetite but
other DCL classes capable of verbal
articulation did not report any strange
occurrences with the hand they said that
they found the hand to look completely
normal and as time went on they began to
trust the ice cream truck with
increasing devotion while their mistrust
in the Disturbed mute declass only grew
in the strangest Twist of all this
d-class was later found dead in his cell
from strangulation the foundation
declared the death of suicide but only
because they could find no other logical
way that the d-class could have died the
d-class was alone in this cell and there
were no signs of forced entry perhaps he
should have enjoyed his ice cream while
he still could you know what they say
ice scream you scream we all scream for
ice cream and no ice cream is more
scream screamworthy than the one served
up by SCP
1386 climbers attempting to summon Mount
Everest and stand on the top of the
world have their work cut out for them
dangers are everywhere on the long climb
there's a risk of extreme altitude
sickness unpredictable winds and
freezing weather there's also the threat
of avalanches great Unstoppable tidal
waves of snow that can bury a person
alive in seconds or strand them leaving
them to freeze to death cold and alone
it's a sad reality that not everyone
that visits Everest comes back down
again and rarely does a climbing season
go by that the mountain doesn't claim
yet another victim situated on the
border between China and Nepal in a
subrange of the Himalayas of Tibet
Everest is one of the seven wonders of
the natural world with an elevation of
29,31 Ft or
8,848 M Mount Everest has attracted many
experienced mountain climbers over the
decades but but even for the most
experienced Mountaineers the Ascension
up its snowy slopes is far from Easy
deaths occurring on Mount Everest are
nothing new and hundreds of people are
believed to have died attempting to
ascend the treacherous Peak sadly due to
the risks involved with carrying heavy
loads down off the mountain many of
those who die on Evers are doomed to
stay there forever their frozen bodies
serving up as their own grave markers
it's difficult enough to move your own
body up and down Everest and in many
situations bringing a body back down is
simply impossible the bodies of these
lost souls are scattered all across and
sometimes underneath the surface of
Mount Everest but some of those bodies
are different from the others and have a
special name within the files of the SCP
Foundation they call them SCP
5140 SCP 5140 is the designation given
to a number of frozen bodies which are
found all across Everest it is unclear
exactly how many instan es of SCP 5140
there are though some estimates have
placed the number at somewhere between 1
and 200 at present it is unknown if all
the instances of SCP 5140 are dead
bodies belonging to climbers who met
tragedy on the tallest mountain in the
world or if some of them are something
else entirely but while their origin is
unclear if you come into contact with a
5140 instance there won't be any doubt
that it's different from the normal body
of a dead climber that's because SCP
5140 corpses are a lot like vampires in
some ways that isn't to say that they
actually are vampires they certainly are
not Undead and cannot function after
death but much like a vampire
traditionally drains blood to survive
these bodies drain heat SCP 5140 corpses
are ectoentropic meaning they do not
adhere to the normal laws of
thermodynamics whenever these cavers are
exposed to sources of heat including
human body heat the corpse will
instantly drain the source of any and
all thermal energy however the
temperature of these SCP 5140 bodies
remains the same regardless of how much
heat they are able to drain staying at a
constant 50° Fen or 10° C should any
living person come into direct contact
with one of the SCP 5140 corpses the
body will absorb their natural body heat
bringing their victim's own temperature
down to 10° Celsius and causing them to
die and once they have died their body
then becomes a new instance of SCP 5140
as a quick side note this might feel
vaguely reminiscent of another anomaly
which features seemingly inert dead
bodies that are hazardous to anyone
around them SCP
2316 this anomaly is a powerful mimetic
Hazard consisting of a large number of
drowned human corpses these corpses are
extremely hazardous to approach at even
a considerable distance
as the mimetic hazard inherent to the
anomaly causes those affected to
recognize the bodies in the water as
people they know particularly from their
childhood like a siren Call the victims
are lured into the water believing that
the familiar bodies are calling to them
if the victims aren't stopped
quarantined and given omnistic treatment
they are essentially considered lost
they will walk into the water and be
absorbed into the collective becoming
just another body floating in the water
while the foundation doesn't currently
believe that there is any official
connection between the two anomalies the
similarities are undeniable and worth
taking into consideration moving on at
present it is unclear whether SCP 5140
corpses are caused by some sort of
infection or parasite that spreads among
the bodies uncovered at Mount Everest if
this is the case the foundation has yet
to uncover the patient zero the root
cause of these infected bodies there is
also little to determine why a deceased
body requires the absorption of heat as
well as how it achieves this and also
keeps its own temperature low but not
frozen given that interacting with an
instance of SCP 5140 can be fatal it
does seem that these anomalous
properties can be passed through contact
and exposure like a disease or a
parasite but there have been no observed
anomalous effects among any living
person visiting Mount Everest there is a
possibility that the SCP 5140 corpses
have developed some form of post humus
mutation that has come as a result of
being killed during an Everest avalanche
and buried in the snow their bodies
starved of heat after death after all
Everest is known for its cold
temperatures occasionally reaching as
low as 1° F orus 17° C not to mention
the difference in air pressure at such
high altitudes as well as frequent
high-speed freezing cold winds at the
summit of Mount Everest wind speeds can
reach up to 280 kmph that is equivalent
to 175 mph and high-speed winds have
even been known to catch mountain
climbers off guard and send them
plummeting to their deaths perhaps the
combination of these conditions the
freezing temperature the air pressure
and the winds have triggered some sort
of change in a number of the bodies
unfortunate enough to never leave the
snow covered slopes of Mount Everest
either that or these abandoned corpses
left in such extreme cold could be the
perfect home maybe some form of unknown
and so far undetected parasite is
capable of inhabiting these frozen
bodies and can spread to other living
hosts by draining them of their body
heat stranger things have certainly
happened at the SCP Foundation and that
could possibly explain why anyone
interacting with an SCP 5140 corpse
meets the same Grizzly fate regardless
of what causes these abnormalities or
why the SCP 5140 bodies have only been
uncovered at Mount Everest close contact
with the corpses often result in
casualties and fatalities naturally this
is a cost the SCP Foundation likes to
avoid as often as it can the nasty habit
SCP 5140 corpses have of draining a
person's body heat makes it impractical
to bring them back to a foundation
research facility for testing as does
the fact that they're on the tallest
mountain in the world instead MTF Delta
14 have been tasked with keeping these
heat thirsty cavers contained to Mount
Everest mobile task force Delta 14 also
known under the code name Winter
Wonderland is formed of a group of
particularly Adept Mountaineers and
experts in understanding and adapting to
particularly brutal terrain without
drawing attention to themselves these
covert operatives are tasked with
periodically climbing Mount Everest and
keeping SCP 5140 contained it is this
team's job to locate any new instance of
SCP 5140 bodies and bury them in the
snow in doing so the goal is to prevent
any unwitting mountain climbers from
stumbling upon one of these bodies and
potentially becoming a new instance
themselves meanwhile the foundation is
pushing for both Nepal and Tibet to
tighten restrictions on climbing permits
but of course the money that Mount
Everest tourism brings to these two
countries has likely impeded this
according to the foundation file on SCP
5140 an incident occurred during one of
mobile task force Delta 14's annual
Everest Expeditions members of MTF Delta
14 had been traversing towards the
Everest summit encountering more and
more of the SC PP 5140 bodies as they
made their way up the mountain just as
they were instructed to do so the team
buried each of the Frozen corpses they
came across under a blanket of snow the
Delta 14s noticed though that there had
been a much higher number of the frosty
cavers on this Mission speculating that
perhaps Mount Everest's high winds had
blown the snow off of ones they had
already buried on previous missions one
of the Delta 14s a man named Charlie
Smith was in correspondence with his
colleagues at their base camp Charlie
reported that one one of his fellow
winter wonderlands Patrick had touched
one of the SCP 5140 corpses when the
team reached the summit and that he was
now buried according to protocols after
becoming an SCP 5140 instance himself as
they began their descent from a topped
Everest Charlie sent an urgent
communication to base camp reporting
that he'd uncovered three more SCP 5140
bodies at an abandoned campsite except
these three instances were different
from any he had encountered before these
Corpses Were Somehow still moving
attempting to hurry down the mountain
Charlie reported that a mass of SCP 5140
corpses were blocking his path and
draining another one of his squadmates
Arnold of his body heat to make him one
of them Arnold had been carrying the
team's Provisions including their oxygen
reserves to combat the lack of
breathable Air at Mount Everest's high
altitude Charlie tried in vain to use
his flare gun to clear the path hoping
to distract the now walking cavers with
a heat Source but it had no effect his
final message to base camp warned the
rest of Delta 14 to not come to the
summit of Everest with Charlie
frantically urging them to not let
climbers anywhere near it his final
message simply stated that the mountain
is danger a rescue division of mobile
task force Delta 14 arrived just under 2
hours later tracking Charlie's last
known location via a GPS Beacon
strangely despite the Frantic messages
from Charlie there were no signs of any
SCP 5140 instances none of the piles of
corpses he had warned them about could
be seen above the snow and certainly
none of them were moving it wasn't long
before the rescue team found Charlie
though he was dead but not drained of
heat or turned into another instance of
SCP 5140 no sadly after bringing their
fallen comrade back to base an autopsy
revealed that Charlie had died likely
the same way so many other Climbers on
Everest had he had suffered from a lack
of oxygen further examination of his
gear revealed that Charlie's oxygen
intake valve had been damaged earlier
while the squad had been climbing to the
summit of Mount Everest his teammates
Arnold Hillary and Patrick Edmund were
also discovered on the mountain but only
Patrick had been turned into an SCP 5140
instance Arnold had simply died from
exposure just like Charlie the rescue
team concluded that due to lack of
adequate oxygen Charlie Smith had
hallucinated the sight of SCP 5140
corpses moving and blocking his path
spending his final moments in Terror as
the mountains condition slowly killed
him the foundation is still unsure
exactly what causes bodies to become
instances of SCP 5140 or even how many
of them are on Everest but a major and
troubling development has recently been
made after an increase in global
temperature led to a large Avalanche
that resulted in a large portion of the
mountain that had previously been
covered in thick snow being exposed the
foundation sent planes that were
equipped with thermal imaging equipment
to scan the mountain what they found was
as confusing as it was terrifying the
SCP 5140 Cor corpses aren't just spread
across the surface of Mount Everest they
are much of Everest the mountain itself
is just a huge pile of corpses just
waiting to drain the life from anyone
who attempts to scale it and turn them
into a permanent part of the peak so if
you were planning a trip to the
Himalayas hoping to scratch climb Mount
Everest off your bucket list maybe give
it a pass otherwise you might find that
the climb is even colder than you were
expecting roll up roll up come one and
oh the circus is in town and not just
any Circus the greatest show in all the
Multiverse don't pay attention to the
fact that the tents weren't here
yesterday or that you don't remember
hearing anything about it before now
that's just the circus magic at work and
there's no circus more magical or more
mysterious than Herman Fuller's circus
of the disquieting it's a show so
marvelous that even the SCP Foundation
wants to get in on the act so come watch
the show come feel the magic after all
what do you have to lose the story of
this humbling Traveling Show begins in
1893 with the founder Herman s Fuller he
was born into a wealthy family and at
the age of 21 he was invited by his
uncle to Chicago to see the buildings
his company had constructed for the
World's Fair he was dazzled by the
sights he saw in the windy city and from
then on he dedicated his life to finding
a way to bring that same awe to people
across America and eventually the world
after receiving a small loan from his
uncle Herman Fuller set about building
the miraculous circus you see before you
today he knew he had to get a leg up
over his competitors after all the 1890s
were a golden age for traveling shows in
America so Herman devoted his time to
research trying to find acts and
Oddities that were truly out of this
world world he learned the way between
worlds stole books from The Wanderers
library and with them studied Alchemy
transmutation sism and other
Supernatural disciplines that real magic
and touch of the macabra would be what
made Herman Fuller's circus of the
disquieting so special and would
ultimately give it its longevity Herman
Fuller's first anomalous acquisition was
a genuine Fiji mermaid like the one that
Fame showman PT Barnum kept on display
around the same time period unlike
Barnum's however Fuller's mermaid had
been brought to life the crowds loved it
but like all attractions pretty soon
crowds grew bored of it and hungered for
the next strange sight so Fuller went
about acquiring more curiosi his next
important acquisition was the man with
the upside down face or Manny for short
he serves as second in command to the
ring master and manages things behind
the scenes including the acquisition of
new Talent many other anomalous beings
and items were purchased for the circus
by Fuller through the auction company
known as Marshall Carter and dark
another group that the SCP Foundation
makes a habit of keeping tabs on another
thing that sets this circus apart from
any others is the clowns because they
aren't like any you've seen before
though Herman fell circus of the
disquieting employs professional clowns
the vast majority of the clown troop are
non-human descendants of an extra dimens
race of magical shape shifters nobody
really knows why they decided to come to
our reality and help Herman Fuller set
up his circus but the leading theory is
simply that they were bored these
original clowns are the progenitors of
the turn clowns and the bread clowns
turn clowns being humans who underwent a
clown transformation procedure and the
bread clowns being artificially grown
children produced by the other two types
earlier in the circus's history before
we knew what we know today about
genetics much more barbaric methods were
used to create new clowns young human
subjects would be subjected to beatings
and painful transfigurations at the
hands of the circus's child breaker
these days however the circus no longer
employs a child breaker instead the
creation of new clowns is the
responsibility of Resident clown breeder
Richard C normis and before you say
anything don't laugh that is his real
name some of the most famous clowns in
the troop are Eugene and PAs both of
which are original clowns Mr Noodles who
is a bread clown and iy the troop leader
who was once a human with magical
abilities known as Veronica Mason she
still possesses her anomalous Powers as
iy and her magic Act is one of the most
beloved parts of our show after the
sudden disappearance of Herman Fuller iy
inherited his position as ring master
and has been doing a spectacular job
ever ever since not every attempt to
create new clowns has been successful as
iy and Mr Noodles though some of the
earlier attempts were quite grotesque to
look at Herman Fuller's troop of clowns
are an enthusiastic happy go-lucky but
occasionally violent Bunch capable of
minor Feats of reality vending that
allow them to perform all manner of
Tricks they live on a diet of mostly
sugar and need to be milked regularly
clown milk is an invaluable substance
here at the circus as it's the secret
ingredient of the famous black cotton
candy which by the way is free with
admission it causes the brain to produce
high levels of Serotonin meaning that
when you eat it your Prime to have a
great time be careful though raw
concentrated clown milk is not for human
consumption though the clowns love to
drink it even a small amount can cause a
human to go into cardiac arest due to an
overload of Happiness The Sound of kapi
Music also go goes a long way to helping
people truly get the most out of their
visit to Herman fullo circus of the
disquieting the kopy is self-playing and
requires rolls of perforated paper to be
loaded into it so that it can play a
variety of pre-programmed pieces of
music each piece produces a different
psychological effect on visitors who
have consumed their cotton candy the
skater's Walts will make them accept
whatever they see at the circus no
matter how weird as nothing out of the
ordinary wonderful for making sure
nobody blabs about their experience to a
certain pesky Foundation officer of the
year makes them less likely to perceive
an event as unlawful we use that one
when we suspect the cops are closing in
hail Hil The Gangs all here is used to
get people to congregate at the big top
for showtime and American Patrol causes
those who have eaten their cotton candy
to seek out those who haven't in order
to strongly encourage them to have some
what do you mean you lost your dog is
one that get gets played after hours
when it's time to get the clowns ready
for milking now that you have an idea of
the history and how things work around
the circus it's time for the tour the
circus is made up of a series of tents
and trailers as well as a Midway with
standard rides and games that you might
find at any circus outside the big top
where shows are performed once a day
there's also the Dena Freaks and the
Hall of humans extraordinaire the den of
freaks is home to Fantastic acts like
Sluggo and Eliza the living head Sluggo
is a man whose eyes are un stocks like
those of a slug and he can bend those
stalks into any shape he wishes he can
even use them to create the shapes of
human faces Eliza the living head is a
woman whose head lives independently of
her body which is safely kept in storage
even without her body she can speak and
sing and often answers questions from
the audience the Hall of humans
extraordinaire is home to Performance
who lack physical anomalies but
otherwise display otherworldly talents
like the amazing zultan a fortune teller
and Alchemist who Fuller picked up at a
place called The utterly bizarre the
Hall of humans extraordinaire also used
to be home to icky the clown back when
she was still Veronica the magician the
recent lineup has changed quite a bit
thanks mainly to the activities of the
circus's constant enemy you guessed it
the SCP Foundation or as they are better
known to the stable of interdimensional
clowns as the Miss SCP Foundation the
foundation does not appear to be a fan
of circus folk and many of the former
acts are now in their containment for
example Madame Rara and her amazing Palm
Reader also known as SCP 1884 a and SCP
1884 B Madame rera was a blind Albanian
woman in her 60s who was born without
hands she shared a psychic link with
with a creature named Luana who was a
large shapeless entity made up of
932 hands 929 of these hands appear to
be those of an old woman and share
Madame barta's DNA but the remaining
three hands seem to be from a male
caucasian adolescent an adult Hispanic
female and a Bengal tiger through her
psychic link Luana acted as Madam rta's
eyes feeling its surroundings to provide
her with a mental map Fuller at wanted
to buy the two of them when they were 8
years old but when their parents refused
he sent Manny to whisk them away under
the cover of Darkness Madame rta's act
involved sending Luana to feel the faces
of audience members and then trying to
describe their appearance based on what
Luana felt the Act was a hit but Madame
Rara claimed to have been horribly
abused during her time with Herman
Fuller the two of them escaped while on
tour and were picked up by old SCP while
trying to to rent a hotel room in the
UAE then this virtuoso also known as SCP
1860 virtuoso was once a book of sheet
music that was transfigured by Herman
Fuller into one of the circus's original
acts it's a tall thin humanoid being
encased in a densely woven paper based
material that stretches like nylon or
spandex it constantly drips black ink
ink which it has a telekinetic control
over it uses the ink to create the shape
of musical notes which float around it
while it sings virtuoso can sing in
multiple voices at once across different
vocal ranges and constantly performs
Aras and show tunes for whoever is
listening it was recovered from
underneath a burnt down Shack at a fail
ground where the circus had been set up
earlier in containment virtuoso still
sings but translations from Italian
revealed that the lyrics of the Aras it
singing have been changed to reflect its
own situation some of these translated
lyrics include one day I'll tell you of
my creation and life within the circus
born from The Ring Master his breed
another act the circus dearly misses is
motor mouth also known as SCP 2094 he
was one of the rare human clowns born in
New York City in the late '70s from
birth he displayed a supernatural level
of flexibility in his lower jaw and as
he Grew Older he discovered that he
could swamp large objects and store them
in a kind of pocket Dimension until he
needed them again unlike Madame Rosara
he went with Manny willingly as even at
8 years old he knew that his alcoholic
mother didn't care if he lived or died
motormouth took to the circus like a
fish to water and Grew From a shy child
into a very talented talkative and
highly charismatic adult he was a
juggler first and foremost who would
catch pins balls and knives in his mouth
as part of of his routine but the name
motor mouth came later in his career
when he let a Stunt Driver drive a car
off a ramp and down his throat however
as great an act he was a conflict arose
between him and Manny over Manny's
questionable methods of sourcing new AXS
Manny found out that motor mouth had
been helping some of the anomalous kids
that Manny brought in to get back to
their families and as punishment for his
insubordination he was locked in a box
and left behind at the end of a Japanese
tour the box was marked for Essie
because many thought being put in
containment was the best punishment he
could think of with how strange and
unusual its acts are and how it always
seems to pop in and out of new locations
at strange and unpredictable times you
might wonder if the circus has any
Sinister motives well the truth is
though sometimes the axe can be a little
gruesome their methods of acquiring new
new talents are a little unorthodox and
the clowns a little out of control their
only goal is to
entertain in that respect they're no
better or worse than any other circus so
we hope you've enjoyed your visit make
sure to stick around for the show and
don't forget to take your complimentary
serving of cotton candy because there's
nothing quite like a day at the circus
especially one like Herman Fuller
addiction it's takes many forms and
wears many faces like a demon walking
Among Us it takes over your life
crawling in and changing you from the
inside out breaking an addiction is hard
but often times not giving it up is much
harder that was a difficult lesson to
learn for three people Joey Walker Dolly
McGregor and Paul Ables these three had
never met one another and now they never
will but each one of them had two things
in common first was that each had an
addiction they felt like they couldn't
shake and second was that they each had
a runin with SCP
666 Joey Walker was at the end of his
rope when he encountered it everyone has
bad days but for Joey every day for the
last 15 years has been a bad day he was
pushing 40 with nothing to show for it
except credit card debt a scraggly beard
and a beat up old Mustang but booze had
always been there for him no matter how
bad things got he could always count on
a glass full of comfort at the end of
the day but to paraphrase a quote by
Stephen King sometimes when a man takes
a drink the drink takes the man and Joey
Walker had been long since taken he was
a transient worker doing jobs wherever
jobs needed doing but he never expected
that he would end up all the way to
Tibet working construction not that he
was complaining sure it was cold but
there was plenty of Tibetan Chang to
enjoy
it was a drink so good that Legends even
say that yetis would raid villages in
the mountains just to get a little taste
Joey had taken a liking to the Chang and
it was what he had been drinking when he
crashed his car up in the mountains
leaving him stranded in the snow Joey
had survived the crash itself but he
knew he wouldn't last long in the cold
he needed shelter that's why he felt
like he could hardly believe his luck
when he first saw the yurt a kind of
traditional Tibetan tent made from
animal skins Joey had never seen
anything quite like it but any Refuge
from the storm would do he pushed
forward through the snow and climbed
inside but the inside of the yurt was
nothing like the outside in fact it
seemed like an exact replica of his
favorite sports bar back in Atlantic
City it was warm there was all the old
memorabilia on the walls and every
screen was showing the Saints wiping the
floor with the Colts in the 2010 Super
Bowl Joey didn't even question it he
just just smiled and approached the bar
he even recognized the bartender Malcolm
a good old friend of his Malcolm smiled
back at him but there was something
oddly menacing in his grin welcome back
he said I thought you'd haul your sorry
keer off to debet guess you gave up on
that too just like everything else well
except Malcolm pushed a glass of beer
towards him across the bar and glared
Joey didn't understand why Malcolm was
being so aggressive but he didn't
question that either he grabbed the
glass and drank it up guzzling it down
before slamming The Empty Glass down on
the bar Malcolm kept the drinks coming
round after round and Joey kept knocking
them back he didn't notice when the TV
screens turned to static he didn't
notice when the other patrons at the bar
began to Jitter and twitch turning
little by little into something less
than human he didn't even notice when
Malcolm's face started melting off his
skull as long as he kept pouring before
he could even really understand what was
happening to him Joey Walker was dead
his liver and kidneys had given out on
him his corpse would later be found
Frozen on the Tibetan Mountain Side just
30 ft away from his crashed car the
coroner's report would list his cause of
death as accidental but this was no
accident he'd Fallen victim to SCP 666
an anomalous year known to some as the
spirit house the being he'd call Malcolm
is known to the foundation as SCP 6 6
6-1 and Joey had failed its challenge
sadly for our inebriated friend the
penalty for failure is death next on our
list of human tragedies comes Dolly
McGregor a 62-year-old woman from
Anaheim California dolly was never
averse to the drink but she knew how to
enjoy her Mojitos in moderation you
rarely get to 62 if you don't and Dolly
could tell people with pride that she
had two children and six grandchildren
whom she didn't see nearly often enough
for her liking she also had over
$100,000 in gambling debt owed to a
number of cinos on the Vegas Strip ever
since her husband Albert had passed away
several years prior shooting craps
playing Blackjack and willing away the
hours in front of the slot machines had
been a welcome change from loneliness
but in Vegas fortunes can change in an
instant Dolly had gone from being on a
hot winning streak to losing everything
the casin extended her lines of credit
until she was gambling with money she'd
never be able to pay back but that
didn't stop her she'd been selling off
everything even remortgaging the house
that Albert had built with his own two
hands to try and keep up with her
ballooning Debs still it wasn't enough
but she couldn't stop either it wasn't
even that she felt good about it anymore
it was just that she only ever felt
normal among the flashing lights of slot
machines and the clatter of dice she
needed to get away as far away as
possible she heard about people reaching
spiritual enlightenment in Tibet they'd
discover God or gods or sometimes just a
sense of inner peace whatever it was she
needed to find it and get this demon off
her back so she took the last of her
savings and flew off to tobet to clear
her head she didn't know if there were
any casinos in Lassa but if there were
her money would surely be no good there
it was exactly what she needed but but
Tibet wasn't the promised land she
thought it would be wherever Dolly went
there she was with the same vices and
demons chasing her the first night she
spent in Lassa she used the hotel Wi-Fi
to download an online poker app on her
phone this culminated in another couple
thousand lost and a panic attack that
caused Dolly to throw her phone into her
toilet before wandering off into the
Wilderness she just needed to get away
but time and space got away from her and
eventually she was KNE deep deep in snow
where had she come from where could she
go it quickly dawned on her that if she
didn't find some kind of shelter soon
she'd be done for but all she could do
was keep walking that's when she
happened upon SCP 666 the yurt was like
an oasis on the barren mountain side she
didn't expect Comfort inside but it
could at least provide her some shelter
until the Staff back at the hotel
noticed she was gone then they'd come
and save her right right but when she
passed through the yak leather flap into
the Y Dolly wasn't in an ancient tent in
the Tibetan Wilderness she was on a
casino floor there was a big beautiful
roulette table before her attended to by
a grinning well-dressed Kier they were
flanked by an army of slot machines and
all the pleasing familiar sounds of
cheerful gambling rang out through the
air she approached the table and the
creier shook his head in what seemed
like disappointment ah back again a
dolly he said with a sigh of course I
should have expected it after all what
else do you have in that empty little
life of yours H without all this you'd
be nothing right nothing at all since
Albert died and the kids want nothing to
do with you we're all you've got so
Dolly what will it be red or black are
you feeling lucky his words wounded
Dolly but that wouldn't stop her she
grabbed her chips and put them all on
red one last spin couldn't hurt what did
she we have to lose she blinked and she
wasn't sitting at the table anymore she
was upright but she wasn't standing her
wrists and ankles were bound to
something to a wheel a giant roulette
wheel like it was some kind of medieval
torture device the cier was standing
across from her well something that used
to be a cier his face was flickering in
and out sometimes it was hum sometimes
it was a mass of eyes and teeth more
demons were were sitting all at the slot
machines behind him pulling levers made
from human bones good choice Dolly the
creier said red suits you he reached out
and gave the wheel a spin dolly was lost
in an overwhelming pulsing Cascade of
Lights colors and sounds the horrific
tinny noises of slot machines and the
laughter of the Demonic cier she was
lost in panic and Terror as she just
kept spinning and spinning and spinning
when her body was eventually found her
muscles were in the advanced stages of
atrophy as though she hadn't been moving
for years her brain was rotted and the
cause of death was determined as sudden
cardiac arrest after an extended period
of sleep deprivation and malnutrition
Dolly's family would never really know
what happened to her the SCP Foundation
has learned a lot about SCP 666 after
containing it in sight 73 its anomalous
effects namely Vivid complex and
potentially fatal hallucinatory
experiences only affect those with some
kind of addiction or dependency to
anyone else entering the yur it's just a
normal tent but any addicts who enter
will fall under its spell and are
generally transported back to the place
where their addiction was at its
strongest there they'll encounter SCP
66-1 an entity that takes the form of a
figure from the subject's life normally
one heavily involved in facilitating
their addiction any kind of addiction
seems to trigger it alcohol drugs
gambling pornography food
self-destructive Behavior even video
games SCP 666 kills its victims with a
twisted mockery of the very thing that
they were dependent on in life it was
only with Paul abeles that the
foundation started discovering the other
side of the coin by almost all accounts
Paul is a worse person than anyone on
this list he got addicted to hard drugs
early on in life and took up a life of
violent crime to support his habit he
murdered two people during a liquor
store robbery before being convicted and
sentenced to death he then been picked
up as a d-class by the SCP Foundation
and selected as a test subject for SCP
666 due to his history of drug abuse the
foundation expected to be adding his
body to the incineration pile sometime
soon none of the researchers working on
the case predicted what actually ended
up happening Paul was forced to enter
the Y not long after he found himself
standing in a place he' done everything
to try to forget the dark graffiti
stained alley Where he'd been sold his
first hit this was the place the place
that destroyed his life every bad
decision he'd ever made could be Trace
back to here and specifically to one man
Frank Frank was his first dealer and now
here he was standing right across from
him once more Frank was grinning like a
demon come on Polly he said you got a
trash we both know what you're going to
do don't you feel it the itch come on
one more hit Polly that's all you need
to feel better it's time to take your
medicine Frank or this thing pretending
to be frank was right he did feel the
itch he did want it maybe he was no
better than this he began to reach out
towards Frank but then he abruptly
pulled his hand back Frank's eyes widen
in genuine surprise as Paul replied I'm
sorry that it's not me anymore SCP 6661
gave a smile and said maybe it isn't
Polly maybe it isn't when Paul Ables was
removed from the SCP 666 year by one of
the attending guards the foundation
researchers discovered something amazing
Paul was very much alive and more
incredibly he didn't feel the Cravings
anymore his addiction was gone and
further tests showed that Paul wasn't a
one-off event in fact anyone who denies
the test temptation of SCP 666 will see
their addictions miraculously disappear
when they finally leave after this it
became clear to the foundation that SCP
666 isn't just a way to punish addicts
it's a kind of test those who want to
change who are willing to truly confront
their demons and resist the pull of
Temptation are rewarded with the one
thing they want most in their life
freedom from their addiction SCP 666 can
be your doom or your salvation
and like most things in life you get
what you give can a thought be
infectious is it possible that
transferring an idea can happen as
easily as catching the common cold
someone gets it then transmits it to
another person who then passes it on to
someone else and so on imagine for a
moment that information is a disease we
can't see information or feel it we can
read it in books or on the internet but
actually seeing it or feeling it inside
our heads is impossible possible so what
if something could taint the information
we absorb use it to slip its way
undetected into your mind then pass from
you to your friends your family your
co-workers how would you know it was
there and how could you prevent it from
getting into your head perhaps it's time
you were introduced to SCP
3002 over its many years of studying and
containing anomalous beings and entities
the SCP Foundation has encountered a
number of creatures with mimic abilities
if you unfamiliar with the term mimic
usually refers to data or information
that has been manipulated in order to
influence or subconsciously change a
person's Behavior this can take any form
from text and images to spoken phrases
and other audio for example a form of
mimetic influence we have all
experienced at some point is product
placement if you ever watched a
character in a movie or on TV using a
certain product then that may have made
you decide that you want to buy that
same product for yourself that idea was
planted in your head by something you
saw and had a subliminal influence on
your behavior SCP 3002 is one such
entity that uses mimetic stimuli for its
own nefarious purposes some anomalies
like SCP 2440 use mimetic information to
spread knowledge of themselves among
human beings getting stronger the more
people learn about it SCP 3002 on the
other hand is information this entity is
a thought a living sentient thought with
a number of abilities that allow it to
influence the minds of human beings it
is hard to picture a thought let alone
one that is alive since we can't see
information the idea of something so
abstract having a tangible form boggles
the Mind SCP 3002 is capable of
shape-shifting and while it does not
possess its own consistent shape the
entity is able to transform itself into
the form of any piece of of information
it chooses existing as pure information
means that it is intangible to any
beings that possess physical bodies but
what makes SCP 3002 a threat to everyone
at the foundation and earn this entity
its ker classification is its power to
manipulate a person's mind or memories
allowing SCP 3002 to directly enter
human Minds moving at the speed that
thoughts can travel through the brain
this entity is almost impossible to kill
or kept contained SCP 3002 can spread
like a sickness through a human
population attacking new minds and
taking control of its victims according
to the foundation's research there's
only one way to remove the influence of
SCP 3002 anyone that comes under the
control of this entity has to undergo
complex intricate and risky brain
surgery in order to physically remove
the entity from their minds however the
foundation considers this method to be
impractical time consuming cost
ineffective and is rendered utterly
pointless if SCP 3002 has infected too
much of a subject's mind so instead in
order to prevent the spread of SCP 3002
influence all Foundation Personnel are
instructed to determinate any person
contaminated by this living thought this
order is extended to that individual's
family friends colleagues and even
acquaintances given that SCP 3002 can
take the form of any information it
chooses written words a sound even a
telepathic signal anyone even remotely
linked to someone The Entity infects has
to be destroyed to stop any potential
spread if you or anyone you knew were to
come into contact with SCP 3002 The
Entity would be able to take control of
your entire Consciousness all your
memories would be ripe for the entity's
picking SCP 3002 is able to sift through
your temporal lobe where memories are
stored and can not only destroy and
delete an infected person's memories but
can also create false memories to
replace them and all the while you would
be completely unaware that this was
happening to you stripped of all your
natural survival instincts while SCP
3002 runs riot in your brain there is
currently no known limit to how much of
someone's mind SCP 3002 is able to mimic
rewrite alter or remove when the entity
Alters one of your memories that memory
will become an additional instance of
scp3 2 in other words it can implant
itself in every moment of your life
making itself a part of everything you
remember about your own personal past
and even the parts you can't once SCP
3002 has spread itself to every piece of
information stored inside your brain the
next stage of infection begins and SCP
3002 is able to take full control of a
person's body much like before this
could be happening to you without you
ever being consciously aware of it you
usually this doesn't come to much and
infected victims will carry on their
day-to-day lives acting no different to
how they would normally that is until
SCP 3002 detects a new Target that
hasn't been infected yet when this
happens any people previously exposed to
SCP 3002 will collectively seek out the
uncontaminated individual capturing them
once this happens SCP 3002 is infected
Army will force their new victim to join
them the SCP Foundation considers SCP
3002 to be extremely hostile and a major
threat to their organization and the
World At Large due to SCP 3002 being
uncontainable and able to infinitely
adapt it has evaded capture or
termination for a considerable length of
time having the ability to spread among
human beings via the information we
share with each other speech texts
emails phone calls any information at
all means that potentially any and all
information could contain as CP
3002 according to calculations of the
foundation's top researchers 78% of
humanity may be under the influence of
SCP 3002 without any awareness that they
have been infected while dangerous and
Unstoppable SCP 3002 doesn't operate
purely on Instinct it doesn't infect as
many Minds as it can just because it
knows no other way everything that SCP
3002 does is a premeditated calculated
decision with one nefarious intention
one goal to destroy the SCP Foundation
From the Inside Out by killing or
infecting every member of personnel
Believe It or Not SCP 3002 didn't begin
life as a sentient infectious thought in
fact SCP 3002 was once a person a
regular human being like you or I she
even had a name Lily Vela it is widely
believed that ly Vela became what we now
know as SCP 3002 due to the actions of
the foundation itself since becoming SCP
3002 Lily seems to have been searching
for any information she can find
regarding a highly secret operation
conducted by the SCP Foundation known as
project Ley as well as this she appears
to have an interest in a number of
foundation research facilities including
site e at an off thee books facility
located in Ukraine's yanin National Park
this is potentially where SCP 3002 was
first created if any of this is to be
believed then it would certainly explain
SCP 3002 is noticeable aggression
towards the foundation and its attempts
to infect its personnel as an act of
Revenge after the project that turned
Lily into a living thought SCP 3002 was
later encountered by the foundation in
its current form in South Rock
Penitentiary this prison located near
Lafayette Indiana was first visited by
one Dr darl Lloyd one of the SCP
foundation's researchers the prison
psychiatrist a woman named Dr Suzanne
Fairbank was the first to notice the
effects of SCP 3002 contamination on a
number of South Rock penitentiaries
inmates during sessions with her several
of these prisoners had mentioned an
identical memory to Dr Fairbank the
description of the memory from each of
the inmates followed the same structure
The Prisoner remembered taking a long
walk through a forest with their best
friend at the time this detail the best
friend is most likely SCP 3002 herself
imitating a figure from each inmate's
own childhood memories at some point in
this false shared memory all the
prisoners recalled having an argument
with their friend it was later learned
that the figure was Lily Vela
approaching infected individuals in
their memories to ask them questions
about the project that had turned tur
into SCP 3002 often demanding to know
what do you know about me or has the
project finished the foundation began to
investigate this bizarre instance of
shared anomalous memory after Dr Suzanne
Fairbank shared her findings on an
internet Message Board describing what
she had witnessed to other psychology
experts at first Dr Lloyd the
foundation's researcher sent to South
Rock to gather more information labeled
the situation as low priority research
given SCP 3 2002's ability to adapt and
take the form of any information it was
able to avoid void immediate detection
by the SCP Foundation and the full
extent of Lily's abilities remained
hidden Dr Lloyd originally classified SC
SCP 3002 as safe believing it was a
little more than a shared childhood
memory that the South Rock inmates had
described at first those that had been
infected with this Collective memory
were able to recount it with perfect
accuracy but as Dr Lloyd continued to
interview and test the affected inmates
the details became scarier and the
memory became less and less less defined
the further the SCP Foundation looked
into it perhaps Lily recognized the
foundation's presence and remembered
that they were the ones responsible for
turning her into a sentient mimetic
entity without physical form and started
hiding her tracks maybe she was biting
herself time hiding herself away in the
minds of the infected prisoners until
the time was right little did Dr Lloyd
realized at the time just how far SC SCP
3002 influence had already spread Lily
wasn't just in the inmates heads but
almost all of the prison staff too who
were now spreading her further and
further without even realizing it
thinking that SCP 3002 would be easy to
contain Dr Lloyd had the foundation
administer adx to all the infected
inmates amnestics are memory altering
drugs that the SCP Foundation uses to
prevent any information about scps
becoming known to the public when
dealing with mimetic anomalies like SCP
3002 or SCP 244 amnestics can be
particularly useful in removing a
person's memories about a mimic SCP Dr
Lloyd hoped that this would be the case
at South Rock still thinking as SCP 3002
was nothing more than an anomalous
shared memory that could be removed
however removing the false memory that
Lily had implanted in the prisoners
would not remove her from all their
other memories additionally one of the
infected inmates was not given amnestics
and was brought back to the foundation
for observation from there SCP 3002 is
influence had been able to spread like a
sickness through the ranks of the
foundation's own Personnel without their
knowledge or detection every person
whose mind SCP 3002 is able to reach
becomes an unwitting carrier for the
Infectious living thought it is unknown
exactly how many of the SCP foundation's
members are under the control of SCP
3002 granting Lily access to the wealth
of secret information and plans that the
foundation keeps hidden it doesn't
matter what level of clearance someone
would need to view it if it's
information it's another way for SCP
3002 to spread and information as we
know can take any form be it a written
file a spoken conversation or even an
informative YouTube video now tell me
again about the time that we took a walk
together in the forest hello again it's
good to have you back and yes we really
do mean you we're aware that you watch a
lot of these videos drinking in all that
classified information about some of the
SCP foundation's most top secret
anomalies you probably think you're
pretty slick don't you as if nobody
could see you peering in and even if
they could they wouldn't remember it
soon after yes you're a very clever
anomaly we wouldn't even think of
arguing against that that's why this
video is about you SCP
3393 don't be alarmed we're on the same
page here we know that you access these
files particularly the files regarding
yourself and your own activities we know
that you're on the shy side and we
definitely appreciate that unlike our
other Shy Guy you don't brutally murder
everyone who witnesses you your greatest
crime is accessing and even tampering
with SCP Foundation files without
permission but seeing as the foundation
is called not cruel we can think we can
forgive that little indiscretion of
yours for the greater good all we ask
for is your attention and a few minutes
of your time you're a vain creature who
or whatever you are so we know you
wouldn't even resist the opportunity to
hear what we have to say about you and
for the record you were one of the few
people who are actually witnessing this
video in the way you're witnessing it
right now it's for your eyes only so to
speak SCP
3393 this video its description and even
the coding of its comment section is
filled with state-of-the-art mimetic
agents cooked up by our best and
brightest to everyone except you the
researcher heading your case the head of
the anti-emetics division and a single
member of the 05 Council this is just
your average run-of-the-mill video this
is a private conversation between you
and the foundation SCP 3393 we hope you
don't mind the designation it's not like
we know your real name but we can make
some rather educated guesses is we
actually know very little about you on
the whole a fact we hope to change in
the future much like several other
anomalies we have files on such as SCP
055 the self- keeping secret and SCP
2256 the very tall things information
recorded about you isn't exactly
sustainable it becomes forgotten or
unreadable shortly after it's noted down
it's a clever anomalous ability and one
we've only been able to counteract with
the application of powerful s drugs but
clearly that isn't the only thing you
have going for you how do you think
you've been able to access all of these
videos filled with classified
information about anomalies groups of
interest and even the inner workings of
the foundation itself through methods
currently unknown to us you've been able
to somehow give your account level four
clearance giving you free Reign Over
almost every file available as much as
it shames us to admit it we haven't been
able to remove this unpermitted
clearance from your account or even
located for that matter like we've said
before you're very clever anomaly we
respect that about you even though
you've been using this apparently crafty
sapiens to inconvenience us our best
guess is that you owe much of your
success to powerful anti-mimetic
properties inherent to your anomalous
being but if we're off the mark on that
do feel free to Enlighten us speaking of
guesses let's get back to what we think
we know about you after all that's why
you're really here isn't it no point
being bashful as SCP
3393 you may be good at hiding yourself
but your intentions are plain as day you
don't need to be a senior researcher
here to int it that much about you the
following are all facts we believe we
know about you with 90% confidence
you'll have to let us know how close we
were in the end assumption number one
you are a corporeal entity that's right
you probably wanted us to assume that
you were some kind of digital ghost
didn't you some mysterious ethereal
thought form existing only in the realm
of cyberspace while you sneak around
site 31 making Mischief we're afraid
that the ghost has been given up so to
speak as clever as you are it isn't
quite as clever as you believe yourself
to be you've gotten sloppy at times and
in these moments you've given us a
wealth of evidence don't you think the
foundation researchers and guards people
train to notice even the most minute
anomalous interference wouldn't notice
doors opening and closing on their own
equipment moving computer terminals
activated despite no digital trace of
approved Foundation login credentials we
must say we're a little insulted by how
much you've underestimated us here we
know the files you've accessed we know
that you're aware of some of the
monstrosities the foundation deals with
ghosts deadly viruses reality warpers
some creatures that can shapeshift or
become invisible deadly memes for
goodness sake did you really think our
Personnel would see the signs of your
meddling and think it was probably
nothing that's a rather dangerous
oversight on your part assumption number
two you're attracted to information
about yourself don't try to deny this
one SCP 3393 the fact you're still
watching this video is proof of your
self Obsession and you've left your
digital fingerprints all over any other
file that made the mistake of mentioning
you we have Pages upon pages of logs
showing your long record of unauthorized
access and the grand majority of the
files you access were about you like we
said you're a vain little creature that
much is plain to see this leads us
nicely on to assumption number three you
seek out this information about yourself
in order to make changes to it or even
delete it entirely if it displeases you
we'll admit this one we find the most
frustrating it's one thing to access
files without our permission quite
another to mess with our heart hard work
we get enough problems from technical
director Rosen already without needing
to constantly pester him about improving
file security the file about you has
undergone a number of needless
modifications and deletions the
following was a personal favorite quote
object class euklid special containment
procedures don't worry I can handle this
description I wasn't supposed to happen
I wasn't supposed to exist at least not
like this but let me deal with it this
thing that I am is best kept away from
all of you don't try to analyze me or
test me or whatever I don't want any of
you to catch what I have just call me
self-containing and will be good end
quote we suppose you thought this one
was pretty funny right you're clearly an
intelligent creature who or whatever you
are but the clear arrogance on display
here doesn't suit you while you may
Coast off of your anti-mimetic
properties it is important to remember
that you aren't Untouchable speaking of
which assumption number number four your
antimimetic properties can be
transferred we found this to be a
particular interesting Wrinkle In Your
Story we know you've got a sense of
humor so you'll have to appreciate the
irony in your attempts to alter or
destroy information about yourself
telling us more about you than we ever
knew before initially when other files
were reported missing we thought you
must have been deleting them out of
spite however upon further examination
we found that the files were still very
much there and you were the last user to
access them this is perhaps the most
dangerous thing about you and we don't
even know if you knew it until now your
antimimetic properties have a tendency
to rub off and affect the things you
interact with with a power like that you
could compromise the whole database and
obviously we can't allow that to happen
assumption number five you have a strong
resistance to mimetic agents much to our
frustration we know that they can affect
you of course but your tolerance is far
higher than that of the average human
being we needed to load this video with
some of our very best just to make sure
it would actually work your mtic
resistance has even foiled certain prior
containment attempts so you've really
been making us earn our keep SC SCP 3393
assumption number six you are confined
to site 31 this is another Inconvenient
Truth for you isn't it first we need to
figure out you're a corporeal being
existing out here in SpaceTime with the
rest of us and then we figure out exact
which space and time you're occupying
Can You Feel The Net tightening around
you 3393 of course we don't want you to
be nervous just sit tight and enjoy the
video you're a very clever anomaly after
all far too clever to be contained by
the likes of us you've been performing
your operations right under the noses of
site 31's most talented Personnel all
the phenomenon we've been attributing to
you from the open doors to the tampered
computer terminals have occurred
exclusively in site 31 and while we may
not be able to track down your account
and strip it of its phony clearances did
you know we can log which computer
terminals unauthorized access to our
files comes from that's just basic cyber
security and we don't need to tell you
that all of your unauthorized accesses
have been logged to site 31 terminals
very sloppy 3393 or should we call you
Dr Macky forgive us if that is in your
name we hate to jump to conclusions here
at the foundation but we couldn't help
help but notice that your anomalous
activity began shortly after a
researcher named Dr Mackey disappeared
from site 31 interestingly much like you
Dr Macky isn't remembered by anyone else
on the site we only know Dr Macky worked
here from records we discovered not too
long ago we know that Dr Mackey was
conducting experiments here though data
on the particulars of those experiments
have been destroyed by you we presume we
also presume that you were most likely
either Dr Mackey or the product of one
of Dr Mackey's experiments we've made a
few attempts to nav you already but
you've always slipped through the cracks
like the sweep of site 31 where we sent
in MTF 8 of 10 C no evil our team that
specializes in combating visual Cognito
hazards those guys are tough cookies and
they're damn good at their job so it is
a mystery how you evaded them our
current best guess is that you were
hiding in some undocumented location
within the site our attempts at mimetic
incapacitation were equally unsuccessful
as we mentioned before it's clear that
you have a greater resilience to mimetic
agents than any of your nonanomalous
counterparts we estimate that even a
kill agent would probably do little more
than weaken you that is impressive we'll
give you that our estimation for why
you've been able to so handedly thwart
our attempts at containing you is that
your access to the system has also given
you access to all of our plans you know
exactly what's going on before we even
execute the attempt giving you time to
think up and execute an effective
countermeasure but we here at the
foundation believe that knowledge is
power SCP 3393 and we have more than
enough to finally contain You Don't
Panic it's already essentially over but
we'll do you the courtesy of explaining
how we got you in the end welcome to
operation bait the hook we know you're
within site 31 and we know you're
attracted to information about yourself
so we limited the scope of where this
handy little video could be viewed to
five terminals in the site we put
measures in place to notify us whenever
the file was accessed and from which
terminal at which point MTF 8 of 10
would be dispatched to seal off all
available exits and quarantine the room
around the terminal a process that would
only take several minutes just enough
time for a vain little creature to watch
a video about itself as it's forever
intuned within the Telltale terminal
that finally gave it away you wouldn't
be brought into a containment chamber so
we simply brought the containment
chamber to you as the network
connections for this particular terminal
are shut off we can safely say you won't
be causing us problems anymore you're a
very clever anomaly SCP
3393 just not quite as clever as us if
you ever take a trip across the pond to
some of the more rural parts of the
British Isles you might just hear some
Tales of a dark shadowy shamee a
creature stalking through the night an
omen of of death it's an entity that has
been known by many names including the
Grim or black Shu most folks will tell
you the same that this nightmare takes
on the form of a huge black dog but is
also known to be able to change its
shape often appearing at nighttime The
Apparition is said to be demonic in
nature commonly associated with the
Devil Himself believed by some to be a
hellhound like garmer and Cerberus
Guardians of the underworld in nors and
Greek mythy ology the dog is far larger
than your average pet with big glowing
eyes it is also known to stock
Crossroads ancient Pathways and places
where executions took place those who
catch sight of black shuck are often
befallen with bad luck and for some it
can even mean that death will soon be
upon them of course this is nothing more
than a bit of local folklore spooky
Tales designed to drum up tourism but is
the black Shu really just a legend or is
there something more to the tail after
all it's not as if a dog like that could
really exist could it enter SCP 023
otherwise known as yes you guessed it
the black shock much like the creatures
from the stories SCP 023 is an entity
possessing a canine form far larger than
most domesticated dogs SCP 023 is
described as being Shaggy in appearance
with black fur and glowing orange red
eyes as well as prominent fangs through
testing the SCP Foundation has
determined a number of the dog's
anomalous abilities first and foremost
Legends have described the black Shu as
an apparition or spirit and much in the
same vein SCP 023 is able to pass right
through solid matter the creature can
pass through walls seemingly at will but
does also seem to have a physical form
at least when it is kept in containment
to prevent a breach the foundation keeps
SCP 023 in a wallof intersection of two
corridors sporting fake doors at three
of its four ends with only one real
entrance why does the dog's containment
unit require such a specific layout
simple it has to resemble a crossroad
even if this is merely a superficial
resemblance remember that the black
shuck of Legend often appeared at
Crossroads a sign that would warn those
traveling of their impending doom as
long as SCP 023 remains con contained in
the cell resembling Crossroads it cannot
pass through walls should the black Shu
ever escape this enclosure however then
it will use its anomalous abilities to
incinerate anything in its path the dog
can burn through walls no matter how
dense and will travel from location to
location by this method also in keeping
with the Shu of folklore looking into
the eyes of SCP 023 can hold potentially
devastating outcomes should any person
make direct ey contact with the do dog
then death will be upon them within the
span of the next full year either the
person who looked at the black Shu in
the eye or close member of their family
will die just like a number of the
Legends State the foundation has no
concrete idea how the shuck chooses its
victims with no patterns or obvious
preferences only that they will die a
year after eye contact researchers
aren't even sure if SCP 023 selects its
victims from the moment eye contact is
made or if this choice ches made during
the year that follows or even if it is a
conscious choice at all all that is
known for certain is that if you were to
look into the beast's glowing eyes there
would be no way for you to tell if you
or a relative would suffer the
consequences only when in the past the
SCP Foundation attempted to eliminate an
individual that looked into SCP 023 eyes
along with their whole family before the
year was up trying to take any potential
victims away from the black Shu before
they could be hunted down by the
anomalous canine much like the way the
creature passes through Walls by
incinerating solid matter the way SCP
023 dispatches its chosen victim seem to
almost be linked to the use of heat the
foundation has conducted a number of
autopsies on those killed by SCP 023 and
their findings have always yielded the
same result anyone killed by the black
shock will not exhibit any signs of
external damage no burn marks on their
skin or any kind of contusions however
on closer inspection these bodies appear
to have been filled in their insides
replaced with highly compacted Ash all
their organs and internal bodily systems
appear to be incinerated by the black
shook but somehow this occurs so rapidly
that there is no notable damage caused
to the outside of their bodies to
prevent SCP 023 claiming any further
victims the foundation has another
measure in place the black Shu has has
been fitted with two spheres made of
hard rubber these are inserted into the
creatures sunken in eye sockets blocking
anyone from accidentally making eye
contact with it however over time thanks
to the heating effect of the shook State
these inserts will begin to degrade when
security cameras detect that the glow of
SCP 023 eyes have returned to a
dangerous level Foundation Personnel
will have to replace the rubber spheres
to once again block the creatur's vision
however this can only be done after
Sunset and any Personnel tasked with
replacing the inserts are caution not to
look the dog in the eyes during the
process unless they want to become the
black Shuck's next victim the SCP
Foundation first came into contact with
SCP 023 when they received information
about an attack that had taken place at
a church while the location of this
incident is unknown if the Legends are
to be believed the church may have been
located in the Moors of a rural region
of the British Isles well while the
church was in the middle of a service
the black shuck entered and killed a
number of civilians in attendance
presumably the members of this
congregation had all at some point seen
the large black dog out in the Moors or
one of their relatives had the
foundation stepped in and managed to
capture the black shook giving amnestics
to the survivors that had witnessed the
attack the Damage Done by SCP 023 and
the deaths it caused were covered up as
attempted arson however the foundation's
trouble with SCP 23 was far from over
after the black shu's capture at the
church the dog was able to breach
containment on multiple occasions at
first it had been placed in a standard
containment chamber but it was quickly
able to incinerate through the concrete
walls of the cell Foundation personel
later discovered that the dog had
settled in in an intersection between
two corridors and realized that it had
resembled a crossroad these exact
corridors became the basis for SCP 023
new containment chamber and the the
assistant researcher originally assigned
to the dog was reprimanded for
negligence during this and other Escape
attempts SCP 023 caused the deaths of a
high number of foundation personnel as a
direct result researchers assigned to it
requested that the black shock be
reclassified as a ker class anomaly they
also noted that SCP 023 shared certain
traits with SCP 111 11-1 one of the two
entities that form SCP 1111 scp1 11-1
also referred to as the white dog
possesses an almost ghostly translucent
canine form and abilities that focus on
Geographic space in the white dog's case
it will attack anyone it detects
approaching SCP 111 11-2 the body of an
unidentified man hanging from a news
researchers working for the foundation
believe that SCP 023 and SCP 111 11-1
might be instances of the same
phenomenon but have been unable to Capt
capture the white dog in order to verify
this given the number of deaths the
black shuck had caused research
Personnel attempted to reduce the danger
that they faced when interacting with
the dog they helped to remove the
beast's eyes and teeth thus making it
safer however it was during an attempt
to do so that SCP 023 once again managed
to breach containment at first
everything seemed to be going according
to plan but when researchers removed SCP
023 eyes the black Shu vanished
completely from its containment area SCP
security staff scoured the area for it
eventually tracking the dog down to a
long stretch of Interstate it is still
unknown exactly how many civilians may
have seen the black shuck as they drove
past it but so far nine deaths are
thought to have stemmed from this
incident the ghostly dog was recaptured
and d-class Personnel removed its fangs
after analyzing the times of incidents
researchers realized that SCP 023 had
only been able to escape while while the
sun was up leading to new containment
procedures mandating that no staff
member was to interact with the shook
until after Sunset the interstate Fiasco
led to the doctor assigned to watch over
SCP 023 being suspended and facing a
disciplinary review from his foundation
superiors the blame for the breach and
security that caused the incident was
placed at his feet and a new doctor was
placed in charge of observing the black
shock unfortunately for this new
researcher the incidents involed solving
SCP 023 did not stop there the newly
appointed doctor attempted to give the
dog a pair of glass eyes to replace the
ones that had been removed before the
previous Containment Breach perhaps they
thought it was a gesture of kindness a
compassionate act or maybe they just
thought it would look cool for a dog to
have glass eyes no matter the reason it
seemed they had forgotten for a moment
that this huge shadow creature was an
ancient evil entity and not a dog at all
when the doctor gave the new glass class
eyes to SCP 023 they immediately took on
the exact same properties as its old
ones they began glowing molten glass
leaking from the dog's sockets and
appeared on all reflective surfaces
throughout the site the Shu was being
held at everything from mirrors and
windows to lenses and glasses computer
monitors anything and everything glass
the foundation suffered an enormous
number of deaths that day even staff
sitting in the cafeteria IO would have
seen a version of those orange glowing
eyes staring at them from the bottom of
their bulls marking them for a fiery
death the facility was quickly evacuated
but the damage had already been done
anyone that had seen a reflection of the
black Shuck's eyes would be dead within
a year devastated the new doctor in
charge of overseeing SCP 023 blamed
themselves for dooming their research
team as well as the rest of the
foundation staff in the facility when
the sun came up over the horizon
a number of d-class personnel were sent
into SCP 023 enclosure only to find that
the dog had once again vanished the only
trace it had left behind was a puddle of
molten glass burning part of the floor a
year later any and all Personnel that
had gazed into the black Shuck's eyes
were dead and their remains were buried
in a mass unmarked grave near the
containment facility despite the doctor
vowing to recapture and contain SCP 023
it remains unclear if they were ever
actually successful there is a chance
that the black shuck has been gradually
making its way back home to the Moes of
the British Isles if so we advise you
not to travel after Sundown unless you
absolutely have to and if you find
yourself at a crossroad then pray you
don't catch sight of a hulking demonic
Hound staring out at you with eyes that
burn through the dark if you do well we
hope you enjoy your year researcher
Ellis was having a very long day working
at the SCP Foundation can sound like a
pretty exciting job to an outsider the
problem is when you deal with something
exciting every day of your life it
starts to become as mundane as brushing
your teeth or pouring your morning bowl
of breakfast cereal over time everything
loses its magic she had the unenviable
job of double-checking the anomalies and
sewing of sight 77 glorified box ticking
she trudged from containment chamber to
containment chamber everything seeming
to be in order tick tick tick it was all
uclid and safe class anomalies anyway
hardly major containment risks but when
she reached the chamber for SCP
2805 the security cameras is normally
used to observe the anomaly were on the
Frets she'd need to go inside great when
the chamber doors opened she felt an
immediate chill her breath came out as
an icy fog in the distance she saw a jar
sitting on a podium the glass so frosted
over she couldn't quite make out what
was inside no sign of a Containment
Breach she ticked the box next to SCP
2805 on her clipboard and moved on
several hours later researcher Ellis was
at home finally able to relax since she
started working at the foundation
dealing with deadly creatures and cursed
artifacts on a daily basis she'd long
for the simple Comforts of childhood in
her downtime that's why she decided to
spend her evening with a warm mug of hot
chocolate a bowl of ice cream and her
favorite animated Disney movie Mulan she
had just pressed play when she got a
phone call from an unknown number with a
frustrated groan she picked up the phone
and answered the voice on the other end
was a little grally but it sounded kind
his diction was old-fashioned a man from
a bygone era why hello there young lady
I hope this isn't a bad time he said the
name's Walt Walt Disney perhaps you've
seen seen some of my Motion Pictures I
was wondering if I could trouble you for
some help with a project of mine this
might have been some stupid prank call
maybe Dr bryatt or Dr klef was bored and
decided they wanted to mess with her the
fact that she was watching a Disney
movie at the time was pure coincidence
after all they own half the movies out
there these days but that's when Walt
carried on talking to her you see my
dear I'm a little short on time at the
moment I realize I um perhaps don't have
the longevity that I used to I won't get
into the illness right now but what I do
know is that I might not be able to put
my final idea into practice and I
believe that you and your organization
may be able to help your um uh what what
is it called SCP Foundation and that
changed everything researcher Alice
immediately knew that this wasn't a
prank call a member of foundation staff
would never discuss Foundation matters
even as a joke over an unsecured line
and a civilian would have no reason to
even know about the foundation was she
actually on the phone with the Walt
Disney it seemed odd and a little more
than unlikely on account of him being
dead for over 50 years if only
researcher Ellice had checked her
clipboard a little closer then maybe she
would have realized that she was already
under the anomalous effects of SCP
2805 also humorously known as Disney on
I here's a fun question for you what's
your favorite Disney movie probably not
what you expected to hear from your
friends at SCP explained but seriously
we want to know tell us down in the
comments maybe you're a classical purist
and you consider Snow White Cinderella
or Sleeping Beauty to be the best maybe
you're a fan of the Disney Renaissance
and it's the little mermaid Beauty and
the Beast or The Lion King that are the
true masterpieces or perhaps you're a
fan of their more modern outings like
Tangled Frozen and Moana or even their
Acquisitions like Marvel movies or the
Star Wars series personally I'm partial
to Tron legacy we could go on but
honestly we'd be here all day the Walt
Disney Company started by Walter Elias
Disney and his brother Roy back in 1923
has become one of the most powerful and
influential entertainment companies in
existence their corporate machine is so
huge and sprawling it Rivals the size
and scope of the SCP Foundation itself
and it's influenced the way we look at
everything from from mice to Pirates to
Norse Legends to Space Battles some give
the United States President the title
leader of the Free World but anyone in
that position would happily drop
everything to take a phone call from the
CEO of the Walt Disney Company even
today the company may be a global
superpower these days but none of it
would have been possible without Walt
himself born in 1901 Walt started his
legendary company at the tender age of
22 who would have known that he would
leave such an indelible mark on human
culture during his 65 years of life but
he's not just an entrepreneur animator
writer voice actor and film producer
he's also decades after his death an
anomaly currently in the capable hands
of the SCP Foundation while his
cryogenically frozen severed head is
anyway and simply looking at that
severed head is what puts such an
anomalous damper on researcher Ellis's
nice quiet evening confused don't worry
let's start this demented Disney fairy
tale at the beginning by which we mean
the end of Walt Disney's life Walt
Disney accomplished more in his life
than many of us would be able to claim
in several lifetimes he' built one of
the most enduring entertainment
companies of all time one countless
Awards and made millions of dollars from
his Creations including the Disneyland
theme parks the man had essentially made
his own name synonymous with magic
childhood Whimsy and dreams coming true
however rather than focusing on the past
Walt wanted to keep his eyes on the
future his Grand Vision went far beyond
movies and theme parks he wanted to
shape the way Humanity lived for
centuries to come and the name of this
Vision Epcot or the experimental
prototype community of tomorrow while
you may know Epcot as a mere portion of
the theme park in the Florida Walt
Disney Resort Walt himself actually
intended it to be so much more as the
full name suggests he dreamed of
creating a functional community of
tomorrow with over 20,000 residents in
his own words Epcot will take its cue
from the new ideas and new technologies
that are now emerging from the creative
centers of American industry it will be
a community of tomorrow that will never
be completed but will always be
introducing and testing and
demonstrating new materials and new
systems and Epcot will always be a
showcase to the world of the Ingenuity
and Imagination of American free
enterprise it was certainly a utopian
idea idea though fans of Bioshock might
find their eye twitching with flashbacks
to Andrew Ryan's disastrous Rapture
however Disney's problem didn't lie in
his plans but in himself despite his
achievements and Larger than Life Legacy
he was still a mortal man when Walt
tragically contracted lung cancer he
finally became aware of the fact that he
may not live to see his beautiful Epcot
dream completed and despite having all
the money and fame a man could possibly
ask for he was beginning to realize that
his fortune couldn't buy him a second of
extra time or could it this question
would soon be answered when
representatives of a mysterious company
known as the onor Roy Collective
approached Walt the strange thing though
was that the entities that compris this
elusive group of interests contacted
Walt in his dreams you see the onoy
collective are a group of entities known
as the onoy or dreamers who exist only
in the dream space but sometimes
interact with with our world through
anomalous sometimes semiorganic
Creations they sell as products in that
sense they were the original imagineers
their Creations include SCP 2028 a few
hundred snow globes that allow the user
to remove and store their nightmares and
negative feelings within and SCP
1498 which are creatures made from
old-fashioned rotary phones trailing a
huge number of wires coiled and arranged
into sheeplike bodies by calling the
phone on the creature's face a person
can order a custom Dreamscape from the
onoy naturally as creatures who depend
on dreams to survive the onoy were big
fans of Walt Disney a man who built a
career of encouraging children to dream
their little hearts out in exchange for
his contributions to the Dreamscape
they'd cut him a deal they'd give him a
special kind of onoy technology that
would allow his Consciousness to
continue to exist and interact with the
Physical Realm after his death all they
need to keep was his head it was
certainly a strange deal but Walt was
thinking of his children his
grandchildren and their children and
grandchildren if he died now then his
Tomorrowland dreams would die with him
he'd simply be known for some charming
animated films and a couple of amusing
theme parks not for truly changing the
future it seemed that the deal with the
onoy collective was too good to resist
the deal was struck and Arrangements
were made to preserve Disney's head and
Consciousness after his death 10 days
after his 65th birthday on December 15th
1966 Walt Disney passed away but that
was only the beginning of his new
anomalous life while the public mourned
Disney's head was secretly removed and
preserved in a jar with anomalous
cryonics technology the device is also
fixed to a pair of rotary phones a
trademark of the onoy and an inscription
that reads Siberian solutions from the
onoy collective the anomalous effect was
simple anyone who looked directly at
Disney's Frozen head would receive a
phone call in the next 24 hours
this phone call would be from Walt
Disney himself presumably inhabiting the
onoy Dreamscape now with this handy
trick he'd be able to maintain his
Communications with the rest of the Walt
Disney Company in secret and see the
creation of his precious Epcot project
to its completion but unfortunately
that's not actually how it happened
following Walt's death his brother Roy
took over all Walt Disney Company
operations while the profitability of
the company didn't suffer under Roy's
control Walt's final dream name dead
Epcot mutated from the sustainable
functional community of the future that
Walt desired into a mere theme park the
disneyfied world's fair that all Orlando
Disney park visitors of today would
recognize as it turned out most people
in the Disney Company weren't actually
eager to take orders from the former
CEO's severed head as a result he became
kind of a dark company secret hidden
away within the Disney parks after a
number of reports of calls from Walt
Disney after the Entre entrepreneur's
death the foundation finally started to
take notice they conducted a thorough
investigation of the various Disney
bases of operation and eventually found
Disney's Frozen head soon redesignated
SCP 2805 in a secret compartment in the
legendary Pirates of the Caribbean ride
he was relocated to site 77 soon after
for further testing where his anomalous
abilities were later discovered sadly
for SCP 2805 while his calls to
Foundation staff have all consisted of a
atts in enlisting the foundation's help
in making his Epcot dreams a reality
nobody has yet taken him up on the offer
since his containment the foundation's
main priority has just been suppressing
conspiracy theories about the existence
of Walt Disney's cryogenically frozen
head a task which they undertake with
collaboration from the Disney Company in
order to muddy the waters in 1981 they
began Productions of Walt Disney's world
on Ice later known as Disney on Ice a
traveling ice skating show since then
they also released the incredibly
successful film Frozen and its sequel to
corrupt any searches for key phrases
like Disney's Frozen or Walt ice it's
been an incredibly effective smoke
screen as you can probably expect from
the SCP Foundation and sadly for Walt
and fans of a mid-century perspective on
the future it's likely that Walt
Disney's dreams will stay within his
disembodied head so if you're hoping to
prove the existence of This truly wild
anomaly or somehow get in contact with
Walton help him bring Epcot to its
intended Glory you should probably just
let it go the SCP Foundation specializes
in tracking anomalous creatures entities
or objects and protecting mankind by
keeping these anomalies contained it
doesn't happen very often though that an
SCP surrenders itself to the foundation
offering to be contained without putting
up a fight you might think that that
would be a welcome change for the
foundation's Personnel getting an easy
containment like like that rather than
having to devote valuable time resources
and even lives to capturing an anomaly
but then you have to ask the obvious and
worrying questions how did this anomaly
know where to find the foundation so
that it could turn itself in in the
first place did somebody send it and if
so why well don't worry you don't need
to try and imagine this scenario because
ANP turning itself over to the
foundation under mysterious
circumstances has actually already
Happened One Day security Personnel at
an SCP Foundation containment site
opened the front door to find an SCP
just sitting there on the doorstep the
anomaly was brought in for questioning
and while it was soon designated SCP 032
it has sometimes been known by another
name brother's bride SCP 032 is a person
or rather a replica of a person not a
living statue that moves whenever you
look away or a wax work that comes to
life when the Sun goes down no this
replica is far stranger SCP 032
resembles a human woman around 30 years
of age who made her who she is supposed
to resemble and just where exactly she
came from are all still questions the
foundation have been unable to answer
but what the research teams have been
able to determine is what she has made
from brother's bride consists largely of
plastics at least the external portion
of her body her skin is made from a
combination of 5. 5 mm thick silicone
and other plastic fiber polymers all
colored with a pigment to more closely
mimic the shade of Caucasian human skin
SCP 032 has been referred to as a type f
human Similac by the foundation meaning
that she has an imperfect outward
resemblance to a human being and the
internal workings of her body are
drastically different from an ordinary
human's organs or central nervous system
what does SCP 032 have instead well she
lacks any skeleton or any any of the
other internal parts that make up a
human body instead her insides are
entirely refined liquid oil however in
spite of having no bones no organs and
existing as just pure oil filling up a
plastic skin SCP 032 has no problem
moving on her own or communicating
verbally when she was first discovered
waiting outside the foundation Slovakian
compound Brothers bride claimed that she
had come there to be stored SCP 032 is
imperfect and how closely she resembles
a human being and this becomes more
apparent the closer one gets to her at a
distance she can maintain some illusion
of appearing to be fully human however
her appearance becomes less and less
convincing as someone approaches
naturally the sight of an uncanny
rubbery Almost Human is enough to
unsettle someone perhaps even cause
discomfort but this also happens to be
unrelated to SCP 032 anomalous abilities
which she detailed to Foundation
Personnel when she was first contained
the Foundation security team that
discovered SCP 032 patiently sitting and
waiting to be found questioned her
motives and how she had come to be there
there was no record of what time she
might have arrived on the compound
security cameras and SCP 032 gave the
Personnel no inkling as to how she knew
the location of the foundation Slovakian
site somehow she'd managed to approach
without being spotted by anyone but
would not explain how she had done so
security Personnel at the site were
obviously skep
and asked brother's bride why she had
come to the foundation SCP 032 claimed
that her creators had commanded her to
that she was to be placed in indefinite
storage until claimed although the
Silicon based woman appears to possess a
normal level of cognitive function she
claims that she is not fully Sapient
meaning SCP 032 does not possess the
intelligence or understanding of other
human beings at least according to her
by her own admission SCP 032 is an
intermediary acting on behalf of her
creators although the SCP Foundation has
yet to be able to verify this as for her
anomalous abilities SCP 032 was kind
enough to detail these to the security
Personnel that first found her she has
an inate ability to influence any
biological entity in her immediate
vicinity in other words any organism
that gets too close well not quite any
there is a limitation to her power SCP
032 can only affect a creature or
organism not created by related to or
influenced by Humanity so plants animals
even microorganisms like bacteria all
fall into the category of things that
SCP 032 has an effect on according to
the various tests the foundation's
researchers have conducted the exact
nature of how SCP 032 abilities Works
seems to vary but her presence always
causes massive and irreversible damage
to an animal or organism's ability to
exchange or use energy for example when
SCP 032 is surrounded by wild Flora
these plants will lose the ability to
conduct the process of photosynthesis
they therefore can no longer produce or
consume energy preventing them from
continued growth and ultimately causing
death in much the same vein any animals
that come into close contact with SCP
032 will find themselves unable to use
their respiratory or digestive systems
rendering them unable to breathe oxygen
or properly consumed food not even germs
and other microorganisms are safe from
SCP 032 effects although when it comes
to these microscopic life forms her
ability seems to focus solely on their
reproductive systems and if bacteria
cannot divide itself it cannot spread at
present the SCP Foundation keeps
brother's bride housed in an automated
containment unit restricting the amount
of direct contact Personnel can have
with her unless they are there to
conduct authorized experiments or other
necessary research related tasks staff
are to leave SCP 032 alone any
interviews with her are not even carried
out in person and instead researchers
use a remote communication array to ask
SCP 032 more about her origin her
creators and her abilities this probably
seems a little over cautious right after
all SCP 032 has no effect on the human
body and isn't aggressive or outwardly
hostile maybe locking her in a room is
excessive but remember her degenerative
abilities do affect microorganisms and
bacteria even those that are beneficial
to human beings the human body is full
of good bacteria that aids with
digestion and helps the body absorb
nutrients like the ones you've heard
about in ads for probiotic yogurt since
032 effects don't discriminate between
good and bad bacteria people have to
keep their distance from SCP 032 or else
they might find that they can no longer
digest food properly in fact no
biological material is allowed anywhere
near her no house plants no pets nothing
oddly SC SCP 032 herself seems fine with
this and has never expressed any desire
for any form of comfort and does not
appear to require sustenance like food
or water shortly after she was first
contained by the SCP Foundation SCP 032
was interviewed by Dr Alexander kovak
the resident psychologist at the site
where brother's bride was discovered Dr
kovak initially tried to ask SCP 032 to
disclose her name however she was unable
to do so I don't have one people have
names I'm not one she then went on to
explain that even her creators had no
name for her and that she was instructed
to cooperate with the SCP Foundation Dr
kovak pressed on asking about when she
told security that she was to be stored
until collected who SCP 032 had meant
was coming to collect her her answer was
as enigmatic as could be expected she
claimed that she was going to be
collected by someone her creators wished
to torment and finding her in the hands
of the SCP Foundation would bring this
person greater suffering kovak asked if
this person was part of the foundation
assuming that SCP 032 creators had some
kind of animosity towards a particular
member of personnel and that 032 was
part of some kind of Revenge plot
against a member of foundation's Staff
SCP 032 denied this though stating he is
not one of you merely a one-time
sympathizer of sorts he believes you
tried to help him once and if he is
forced here if he finds me here you will
die that will hurt him they have no
interest in any of you or your
organization you are here as a tool just
as I am according to SCP 032 the man
coming to collector was a prideful
complacent figure who won when he should
have lost somehow this individual had
apparently been punished by being forced
to live an exile from his kin and wander
the world endlessly destroying anything
in his path yet unwillingly his very
presence would poison human beings
leaving this man trapped in Eternal
Solitude tormented by the weight of his
guilty conscience SCP 032 described the
man's punishment as a Masterwork of
Torment she described her purpose in
being sent to the foundation as being to
act as this man's last undoing
apparently this Wanderer would
occasionally find solace in looking at
nature and find Hope in the world around
him her ability to destroy the organisms
around her would be a way to break this
man's well and the final nail in the
proverbial coffin apparently SCP 032 is
appearance was also seemingly meant to
deceive him she stated that the man
would recognize her and this would
remind him of fond memories but then as
he got closer he would see SCP 032 for
what she really was a crude replica of a
human being reminding this man that her
likeness would be forever out of his
reach SCP 032 was intended by her
creators to be as artificial as the
wandering man's hope and when he
eventually found her either in a day a
month or in a century she would destroy
his very last source of Solace at the
conclusion of the interview Dr kovak
asked why this man would recognize her
and SCP 032 simply replied used to be
his wife if we take SCP 032 at her word
then it appears she was created with the
intention of being used to torment this
wandering man and act as a final
punishment for him in another interview
6 months after her initial containment
SCP 032 expressed a hatred for the man's
wife whom she was made to resemble sent
in to assess SCP 032 cognitive abilities
and personality or lack of Dr kovak
questioned this scp3 32 had always been
adamant that she had no conscious
thoughts or feelings of her own and when
challenged by the doctor she claimed
that she hated her mold because her
creators wanted her to the first thing
SCP 032 creators had done after making
her was show her the wife of the man
they hoped to torment it is unclear
whether SCP 032 was shown photographs or
the actual woman she had been molded
from not an easy task as this woman the
wife was a apparently long dead but the
creators had risked disturbing the
wife's final rest just to show her to
SCP 032 she was beautiful so peaceful
Serene whole even gone even dead I could
see the essence of who she used to be of
who she still was and forever will be
her soul they told me she didn't get to
live for all that long but when she
lived she was herself she was alive and
so I hated her in the wife's face SCP
032 saw a reflection of herself and
realized that she had been made just to
be a mockery a parody of a living human
being existing only to cause misery to
the wandering Man Who Would One Day find
her instead of skin she had molded
silicone and plastic synthetic fiber in
place of hair and oil for blood but what
SCP 032 lacked she realized was a soul
this was all part of the mother's design
according to SCP 032 when the man found
her he would see not only what had been
done to the memory of his wife but he'd
also see how much SCP 032 hated her and
hated herself for not being alive the
same way the wife had been the goal of
all of this to make the man realize that
he never won SCP 032 herself is a
mystery but perhaps the real question is
who do you think this this man is and
what was it he didn't win but that's a
story for another day let us know what
you think down in the comments a shot
zipped past his head nearly missing
leaving an indent on the wall mere
inches away he froze peeking out from
cover scanning the area for any sign of
the enemy nothing not a single movement
but still he didn't feel the least bit
safe there was a more secure stronghold
a bunker only a short Dash from where
was squatting ripping his weapon close
to his chest private Mitchell took a
deep breath psyching himself up before
rushing across the battlefield towards
what he hoped would be better cover
ducking under a camouflage tarp that
covered the entrance Mitchell was met
with the sight of a squadmates all
sitting huddled in the Foxhole some
looking dejected and miserable others
cowering in fear all apart from Sergeant
King who sat cross-legged in one corner
wearing a permanently crazed wide-eyed
stare on his face and a exhausted
private Mitchell sat down with the
others unable to offer more insight than
a nod of mutual condolence to his
comrades for a while the members of MTF
Iota 17 the unit code named the
Greendale humans found themselves
feeling the simultaneous mix of
frightened and bored each one of them
could have achieved the same sense of
anxiety by drinking 10 cups of black
coffee loudly knocking on their drill
sergeant store in the middle of the
night then rushing back to their
Barracks to hide under their bunks
movement from outside caused the whole
team's heads to swivel peeking out of a
gap in the outer wall of the bunker they
saw the enemy immediately two of the
ghostly incorporeal figures roaming the
battlefield outside not to be
underestimated despite the baggy
oversized tactical gear they wore and
weapons that looked too big for them and
two outside meant the other three were
still out there somewhere one gave a nod
to the other instructing him to scour
the area surrounding the bunker Mitchell
was terrified and all tooo aware that
there were too many of them in the
bunker the enemy was bound to find them
soon all of a sudden Sergeant King
seemed to stir from his strange trance
and produced a box of matches he held
out four in his hand keeping them
covered so that nobody could tell if
they were picking a long one or a short
one the first of MTF Iota 17 private
Davis reached for a match as they were
offered his heart dropping as sergeant
King pointed it was a short one next
private Byron picked out a match a long
one private Mitchell's pulse skyrocketed
as sergeant King offered him the
remaining two knowing that one would be
long the other short he reached out and
plucked a short one king explained that
the First Short Straw and the first long
strong go bad luck Byron and Davis but I
don't make the rules Byron not wanting
to be at the mercy of the spirits
protested that those rules seemed made
up but private Mitchell even less eager
to go out there affirmed the Sergeant's
logic hanging their head heads both
private Byron and private Davis gathered
up their weapons and sluggishly walked
out of the bunker moments later still
safe inside private Mitchell overheard
the enemy taking fire followed by the
sound of splattering and Yelps of pain
from his two Fallen squadmates he
offered a concerned look to Sergeant
King whose wide-eyed expression was
doing little to ease Mitchell's nerves
they got our voice good King muttered
rocking slightly Tagg them like the
Bowery wall still lucky they didn't get
hit by the camp cannon ball Mitchell
asked in disbelief whether the enemy
really had their hands on a cannon no no
The Cannonball is just their name for it
the sergeant said solemnly I've never
seen it myself but I heard rumors
apparently these incorporeal delinquents
sneak a steel ball in with their ammo
that's their way of keeping things
interesting who was it that said war is
Hell or was it War makes people crazy
crazy I was crazy once Mitchell sighed
and asked why they don't just throw in
the towel and surrender you know darn
well why the Mad commanding officer
barked chaos Mass hysteria a whole new
mess for the foundation to clean up and
you listen here maybe you can live with
that but not me not on my watch the
private asked to be let in on the battle
plan unsure if he was more scared of
Sergeant King With the Enemy outside we
should drag one of them in here get him
to give up enemy intel King answered in
a Sinister unhinged tone he didn't
respond well when told that the
intangibility of the enemy may make
holding one of them hostage while
impossible still living in a fantasy are
you private King chuckled maniacally and
didn't stop for a full unsettling minute
look I've had it up to Here With the
Enemy and their dirty tactics I say it's
time we went full Return of the Jedi
we're the Ewoks and they're the Empire
now belt up and bear out grabbing his
weapon Sergeant King suddenly hopped to
his feet and bellowed letting out a
primal scream up towards the heavens
then he rushed out of the bunker
screaming his own name until a barrage
of enemy fire opened up from all
Direction CS still cowering in the
safety of the bunker private Mitchell
sighed again as he looked at his
commanding officer covered in splatters
of paint fortunately for Mitchell and
the rest of MTF Iota 17 the injuries
they had sustained in the line of duty
were nonfatal save for a few bruised
Egos and some stubborn paint stains on
their uniforms that took a lot of
seltzer water and lemon to wash out the
unfortunate downside however was that
their defeat led to a localized
anomalous event the perpetrators of that
incident five ghostlike entities with a
bad habit of painting the town red
literally meet SCP
2629 sometimes more commonly referred to
as the 29-year paintball war see if you
can guess how it got that nickname
located on the outskirts of CRA out
Poland one can find an abandoned
building that was previously used as an
indoor paintballing venue but now it's
known to the SCP Foundation by its
designation of SCP
2629 inhabiting the location are a
number number of incorporeal entities
collectively known as SCP 26
29-a these are humanoid in their shape
and behavior but largely intangible
however there are a few caveats to that
which we'll Circle back to as for their
appearance despite being somewhat
translucent facial recognition software
deployed by the foundation has
determined that these so-called ghosts
bear a resemblance to a group of five
teenagers all of whom died during a
driving accident according to local
police records these deaths took Place
approximately 5 km outside of krackow
and there are no existing records that
indicate the teenagers in question ever
frequented the paintball venue while
they were alive anyway now we mentioned
not too long ago that these five
entities aren't entirely incorporeal or
at least they aren't 100% intangible the
exceptions here are the projectiles
fired from their weapons in this case
standard paintballs with no anomalous
properties remain physically tangible
they interact with the world in the same
way you would expect any normal
Paintball 2 splattering on impact with
solid matter usually a hard surface or a
human target and this exception to
intangibility also works the same way in
Reverse any paintballs fired at any of
SCP 2629 daa will have the same expected
effect any and all attempts by the SCP
Foundation to engage in Direct
Communications with SCP 26 29-a have
resulted in Failure while they will
often engage in banter and trash talk
with their opposition during games they
seem to be uninterested in talking about
anything other than paintball during one
attempt by Foundation researcher Dr Ben
kazarin to talk with the entities and
ask why they spend eternity in a
paintball Arena the only answer given by
one of the anomalous ghosts SC SCP 2629
a-2 was why not every afternoon at
exactly 1:00 Central European Time all
members of SCP 2629 daa will manifest
within SCP 262 29 should they be left
unattended they will begin to roam
freely often gravitating towards the
nearby neighborhood this can lead to an
event classified as an a 2629 scenario
however the occurrence of an a scenario
can be averted should the five entities
be engaged in a game of paintball it is
the only known measure to deter them and
as such the SCP Foundation has assigned
mobile task force Iota 17 to deal with
the problem every day all members of MTF
Iota 17 the Greendale humans enter the
paintball facility via an underground
tunnel each of these operatives
possesses a high level of proficiency in
Marksmanship as well as close quarters
combat utilizing firearms on top of that
the foundation insists that MTF troops
in this unit also need to be great at
paintball the foundation's MTF agents
must Engage The Five members of SCP 26
29-a in a game of paintball shortly
after the entities manifest at 1:00 the
games follow the traditional capture the
flag rules where in both team teams have
a flag that they need to protect while
also being tested with securing the
opposing team's flag should the
foundation's pro paintballers be
successful in winning the match then all
instances of SCP 26 29-a will Dem
manifest peacefully until they return at
the same time the following day but
should the five ghostly teammates
Prevail or if MTF Iota 17 breaks any of
the conventional paintball rules then
this will trigger an Alf 2629 scenario
but exactly how long has this protracted
paint War been going on for well the
clue is in the nickname all the way back
in 1988 the SCP Foundation received
reports of unusual vandalism taking
place in the area near Krakow that might
have been enough to pique their initial
interest but the sudden reported
sightings of ghosts by local civilians
was what really made them take interest
descending on the small area outside of
Kau the foundation launched a full-scale
investigation into SCP
2629 given what we now know about the
anomaly it seems that that with no one
to challenge them the five paintballing
entities were free to enact an Alf 2629
scenario unobstructed once the
foundation discovered the site of SCP
2629 and determined it to be the source
of the local anomalous activity they got
to work evacuating the immediate
vicinity of the abandoned paintball
Arena and devising containment
procedures to keep unwitting civilians
from getting caught in the crossfire of
an imminent paints slinging conflict as
far as the public would know the
abandoned SCP 2629 venue was shut down
thanks to a hazardous amount of asbestos
its entrances were sealed off to deter
vandals and would be Urban explorers but
in reality the foundation was keeping
people out so that the first match
between their team MTF Iota 17 and the
five members of s SCP 26 29-a could
commence the battle was relentless
paintballs flying in all directions
splattering any in their path the
foundation lost a lot of good men that
day although they quickly found them
again once they' cleaned up all the
paint in an attempt to shift the tide of
battle and turn the odds in the
foundation's favor MTF operatives
rearranged some of the indoor playing
field this however was an ill-advised
strategic misstep as messing with the
venue's cover violated the established
rules of paintball and doing so caused
an Al 2629 scenario to begin in response
a number of Al 2629 procedures have been
put in place to combat the anomalous
event staff at site 19 had to equip the
protective paintballing gear stored at
their workstations or in lockers around
the facility if any of them couldn't
access their gear the next best thing
Foundation Personnel could do was cover
their eyes and ears until the event
passed any and all delicate equipment
had to be stored for safety purposes
security staff are tasked with making
sure any scps that might be vulnerable
are kept out of Harm's Way the
foundation currently has no way of
barring SCP 2629 daa's access to areas
thanks to their
incorporeality however they can be
deterred by being presented with an
abundance of Target targets staff are to
remain on high alert until the AL 2629
scenario is over and the all clear
signal sounds with all this preparation
taking place at site 19 no less you'd
expect an Al 2629 scenario to entail
something pretty catastrophic it wasn't
always such an issue during the initial
decade following SCP 26 29's Discovery
the AL if scenario used to entail the 5
SCP 26 29- entities roaming the nearby
area of crackout an opening fire on
people and property with their paintball
guns hardly a paint-based war crime but
definitely goes an unnecessary extra
mile in terms of vandalism then again
you try being stuck for an eternity in a
paintball Arena sometimes it's nice to
stretch the invisible space where your
legs used to be and by now you've
probably made the connection the unusual
vandalism that Drew the foundation to
SCP 2629 in the first place was the
ghostly teenage paintballers literally
Painting the Town whenever they
manifested only to fade away after a few
hours but that's only what the AL if
scenario used to entail it happened
during the 12th consecutive year of the
paintball war a third MTF loss against
SCP 26 29-a caused yet another Al if
scenario to activate but this time
instead of roaming the local
neighborhood the incorporeal teens
Victory sent them to one of the
foundation's most highly guarded
facilities site 19 multiple unsuspecting
Foundation research Personnel were
splattered with paint the first of the
paintball wars casualties to fall
outside of a two 150 M radius from SCP
2629 the foundation launched an inquiry
into how these five incorporeal
anomalies were able to breach the
security of site 19 citing loose lips
among MTF Iota 17 about site 19 as such
they were banned from ever mentioning
Foundation operations during their
paintball skirmishes with SCP
2629 however the lasting damage was
already done and unlike a paintball
splatter there was no wiping this away
or covering it up every loss that that
MTF Iota 17 incurred in the coming years
would result in all five of SCP 26 29-a
manifesting within site9 celebrating
their Capture the Flag victories by
committing paintball retribution against
Foundation Personnel staff and corridors
were splattered with paint and attempts
to return paintball fire were
unsuccessful in dispersing the
incorporeal attackers one researcher
even sustained an eye injury after being
struck in the eye by a straight
paintball as the years rolled on MTF
Iota 7 's losses began to increase
rapidly more and more Al 2629 scenarios
were occurring each year Foundation
facilities abruptly and messily
redecorated by a volley of paintballs
the site9 director issued a communic to
the Ethics Committee requesting the
termination of SCP
2629 MTF Iota 17 may have some of the
best trained people in the world but SCP
2629 have been gaining experience for
decades it was only a matter of time
before the skill Gap closed anyone we
recruit to fill a vacancy in MTF Iota 17
is going to need to be able to counter
nearly 30 years of paintball experience
and that number is always growing all
five of SCP 26 29-a had already gotten
tired of trashing their own neighborhood
and before long they'd similarly get
bored of trashing site 19 the question
was once that happened where would they
hit next now check outp chaos Insurgency
explained and I survived 100 days
infiltrating the chaos Insurgency here's
what happened for more